No,
well thank you all very much for coming.
It's really shocking to me that you
don't have anything better to do on a
Tuesday.
No,
seriously though.
It is.
I mean,
you know,
it's,
it's very strange in some sense that
there's so many of you here to listen to
a sequence of psych,
of lectures on the psychological
significance of the biblical stories.
It isn't something I've wanted to do for
a long time,
but it still does surprise me that
there's a ready audience for it and.
Well,
so that's good.
So we'll see how it goes.
And uh,
I'll start with this because this is the
right question.
The right question is why bother doing
this?
And I don't mean why should I bother
doing it?
I have my own reasons for doing it,
but you might think,
well,
why bother with this stranger will book
at all.
And that's a good question.
You know,
um,
it's a contradictory
document that's been cobbled together
over thousands of years.
It's outlasted kingdom,
this many,
many kingdoms.
You know,
it's,
it's really interesting that it turns
out that a book is more durable than the
stone.
It's more durable than a castle.
It's more durable than an empire,
and that's really interesting.
You know that.
It's something in some sense,
so evanescent can be so long living,
so there's that.
That's kind of a mystery.
I'm,
I'm approaching this whole scenario.
This is the biblical stories as if
they're a mystery fundamentally because
they are.
There's a lot we don't understand about
them.
We don't understand how they came about.
We don't really understand how they were
put together.
We don't understand why they had such an
unbelievable impact on civilization.
We don't understand how people could
have believed them.
We don't understand what it means that
we don't believe them now or or even
what it would mean if we didn't believe
them there.
There's and then on top of all that
there's the additional problem,
which isn't specific to me but is
certainly relevant to me that no matter
how educated you are,
you're not educated enough to discuss
the psychological significance of the
biblical stories,
but I'm going to do my best and partly
because I want to learn more about and
one of
the things I've learned is that the best
way to learn about something is to talk
about it and when I'm lecturing I'm
thinking,
you know,
I'm not trying to tell you what I know
for sure to be the case because there's
lots of things I don't know for sure to
be the case.
I'm trying to make sense out of this and
I have been doing this for a long time
now.
Know you may know you may.
Not that I'm an admirer of Nisha.
Nisha was a devastating critic of,
I would say dogmatic Christianity.
Christianity as it was instantiated in
institutions,
I suppose.
Although he.
He's a very paradoxical thinker because,
for example,
one of the things you said was that he
didn't believe that the scientific
revolution would have ever got off the
ground if it hadn't been for
Christianity and more specifically for
Catholicism because he believed that
over the course of really a thousand
years,
the European mind,
so to speak,
had to train itself to interpret
everything that was known within a
single coherent framework,
coherent.
If you accept the initial axioms,
a single coherent framework and so neat,
you believe that that catholicized of,
of,
of the phenomena of life and of history
produced the kind of mind that was then
capable of transcending that it's
dogmatic foundations and then
concentrating on something else,
which in this particular case happened
to be the natural world and so need you
to believe that in some sense,
Christianity died at its own hand.
It had spent a very long period of time
trying to attune people to the necessity
of the truth.
You know,
absent the corruption and all of that,
that's always part of any human
endeavor.
And then the truth,
the spirit of the truth that was
developed by Christianity turned on the
roots of Christianity and everyone woke
up and said something like,
or thought something like,
well,
how is it that we came to believe any of
this?
Um,
it's like waking up one day and noting,
noting that you really don't know why
you put a Christmas tree up,
but you've been doing it for a long time
and that's what people do.
And I know there are reasons that
Christmas trees came about,
but the,
what would you say?
That ritual lasts long after the reasons
have been forgotten.
So now Nicha,
although he was a critic of Christianity
and also a champion of,
of its disciplinary capacity,
because you see,
the other thing that needs you to
believe was that it was not possible to
be free in some sense,
unless you,
unless you had been a slave.
And by that he meant that you don't go
from childhood to full fledged adult
individuality.
You go from childhood to estate of
discipline,
which you might think is akin to
slavery,
to self imposed slavery.
That that would be the best scenario
where you have to discipline yourself to
become something specific before you
might be able to retain the generality
that you had as a child.
And he believed that Christianity had
played that role for Western
civilization.
I'm,
but in the late 18 hundreds,
he announced that God was dead and you
often hear of that as something
triumphant,
but for her it wasn't because he was too
nuanced.
The thinker to be that simple minded.
See Nicha understood that this is
something I'm going to try to make clear
is that we,
there's,
there's a very large amount that we
don't know about the structure of
experience that we don't know about
reality and we have our articulated
representations of the world.
And then you can think of outside of
that,
there are things we know absolutely
nothing about and there's a buffer
between them.
And those are things we sort of know
something about and we don't know them
in an articulated way.
Here's an example.
You know,
sometimes you're arguing with one of
your,
someone close to you and they're in a
bad mood,
you know,
and uh,
they're being touchy and unreasonable
and it keep the conversation up and
maybe all of a sudden they,
you know,
they get angry or maybe they cry and
then when they cry they figure out what
they're angry about and it has nothing
to do with you.
Even though you might have been what
precipitated the argument,
you know,
that's an interesting phenomena as far
as I'm concerned because it means that
people can know things at one level
without being able to speak what they
know at another and so in,
in some sense,
the thoughts rise up from the body and
they,
they do that in moods and they do that
in the images and they do that in
actions.
And we have all sorts of ways that we
understand before we understand in a
fully articulated manner.
And so we have this articulated space
that we can all discuss.
And then outside of that we have
something that's more akin to a dream
that we're embedded in.
And it's an emotional dream that we're
embedded in and that's based at least in
part on her actions.
I'll describe that later.
And then outside of that is what we
don't know anything about at all.
And in that dream,
that's where the mystics live and that's
where the artists live and there are the
mediators between the absolute unknown
and the things we know for sure.
And you see what that means in some
sense is what we know is established on
a form of knowledge that we don't really
understand.
And that if those two things are out of
sync.
So you might say if our articulated
knowledge is out of sync with our dream,
than we've become dissociated
internally.
We think things we don't act out and we
act out things we don't dream.
And that produces a kind of sickness of
the spirit and,
and that sickness of the spirit it see
it.
It's cure or is something like an system
of belief and representation.
And then people turn to things like
ideologies,
which I regard as parasites on an
underlying religious substructure to try
to organize their thinking.
And then that's a catastrophe.
And that's what Nisha Nisha foresaw,
you see,
he knew that when we knocked the slats
out of the base of Western civilization
by destroying this representation,
this is God ideal,
let's say,
that we would destabilize and move back
and forth violently between nihilism,
let's say in the extremes of videology.
He was particularly concerned about
radical leftist ideology.
You know,
unbelieved in predicted this in the late
18 hundreds,
which is really an absolute intellectual
tour.
De Force of staggering magnitude
predicted that in the 20th century that
hundreds of millions of people would die
because of the replacement of these
underlying dreamlike structures with
this rational,
rational but deeply incorrect
representation of the world.
And you know,
we'd been oscillating back and forth
between left and right in some sense
ever since.
And you know,
with some good sprinkling of nihilism in
there and despair in some sense,
that's the situation of the modern
western person and in an increasingly
have people in general.
You know,
I think part of the reason that Islam
has its backup with regards to the west
to such a degree.
I mean,
there's many reasons and not all of them
are valid,
that's for sure.
But one of the reasons is that,
you know,
they,
they being still grounded in a,
in a,
in a dream,
let's say,
they can see that the root less
questioning mind of the west pope poses
a tremendous danger to the integrity of
their culture now.
And it does,
I mean Westerners,
us,
we undermine ourselves all the time with
our searching intellect.
And I'm not complaining about that at,
you know what I mean?
It,
it,
there isn't anything easy that can be
done about it,
but,
but it's still,
it's still sort of what fruitful
catastrophe and you know,
it has real effects on people's lives.
It's not some abstract thing,
you know?
I mean,
lots of times when I've been treating
people for depression,
for example,
or anxiety,
they have existential issues.
You know,
it's not just some psychiatric
condition.
It's not just that they're tapped off of
normal because their brain chemistry is
faulty.
Although,
you know,
sometimes that happens to be the case.
It's that they are overwhelmed by the
suffering and complexity of their life
and they're not sure why it's reasonable
to continue with it.
You know,
that they can feel that terrible
negative meanings of life,
but are skeptical beyond belief about
any of the positive meanings.
I had one client who was a very
brilliant artist and as long as he
didn't think he was fine,
you know,
because he'd go and create and who is
really good at being an artist.
He just,
you know,
he had that personality that was
continually creative and quite
brilliant.
Although he was self denigrating and.
But as soon as he started to think about
what he was doing,
then you know,
the,
it's like a,
like a drill or a saw or something like
that.
He'd saw the branch off that he was
sitting on because it starts to
criticize what he was doing.
Even the utility of it,
even though it was sort of self
evidently useful and then he would be
that.
It would be very,
very hard for him to even motivate
himself to create an he,
I,
he always struck me as a good example
of,
of the consequences of having your
rational intellect divorced in some way
from your being divorced enough so that
it actually questioned the utility of
your being.
And it's not a good thing.
It's not a good thing and it's,
it's,
it's really not a good thing because it
manifests itself not only an individual
psychopathology but also in social
psychopathology.
And that's his proclivity of people to
get tangled up in ideologies,
which,
which I really do think of as,
as they're like,
they're like crippled religions.
That's the right way to think about
them.
They're like a religion that's missing
an arm and a leg,
but can still haul bill along and it,
it provides a certain amount of security
and group identity,
but it's,
it's warped and twisted and demented and
banter and it's a parasite on something
underlying that's rich and true.
And that's how it looks to me anyways.
And,
and so.
So I think it's very important that we
sort out this problem.
Um,
I think that,
I think that there isn't anything more
important that needs to be done than
that I've,
I've thought that for a long,
long time,
probably since the early eighties when I
started looking at the site,
the role that belief systems played in
regulating psychological and social
health,
um,
because they,
you can tell that they do that because
of how upset people get.
If you challenge their belief systems.
It's like,
why the hell do they care?
Exactly what difference does it make if,
if all of your ideological axioms are
100 percent correct?
Like people get unbelievably upset when
you,
when you poke them in the axioms,
so to speak.
And it isn't,
it is not by any stretch of the
imagination obvious why,
you know,
but there's some,
it's like there's a fundamental truth
that they're standing on.
It's,
it's,
it's like they're on a raft in the
middle of the ocean and you're starting
to pull out the logs,
you know,
and they're afraid they're gonna fall in
and drown.
It's like drowning.
What and what are the logs protecting
themselves,
protecting them from and why are they so
afraid to to move beyond the confines of
the ideological system and like these
are not obvious things,
so I've been trying to puzzle that out
for a very long time and I've done some
lectures about that that are on youtube.
Most of you know that some of what I'm
going to talk about in this series,
you'll have heard if you've listened to
the youtube videos,
but you know I'm trying to hit it from
different angles and so okay,
so niches.
Idea was that human beings,
we're going to have to create their own
values essentially.
Now he understood that we have bodies
and that we had motivations and emotions
like he was a romantic thinker in some
sense but way ahead of his time because
he knew that our capacity to think
wasn't some free floating soul,
but was embedded in our physiology,
constrained by our emotions,
shaped by our motivation,
shaped by our body.
He understood that,
but he still believed that the only
possible way out of the problem would be
for human beings themselves.
To become something akin to God and to
create their own values that was steps
and he thought that the person,
he.
He talked about the person who could
create their own values as the overman
or the superman and that was one of the
parts of the Nietzschean philosophy that
the Nazis,
I would say took out of context and used
to fuel their superior man ideology.
So we know what happened with that.
That didn't seem to turn out very well.
That's for sure.
And See.
I also spent a lot of time reading Carl
young and it was through you and also
John,
Piaget's developmental psychologists
that I started to understand that are
articulated systems of thought are
embedded in something like a dream.
That dream is informed in a complex way
by the way we act.
So you know,
we act out things we don't understand
all the time and if that wasn't the case
then we wouldn't need a psychology or
sociology or in anthropology or any of
that because we would be completely
transparent to ourselves.
And we're clearly not.
So we're much more complicated than we
understand.
Which means that the way that we behave
contains way more information than we
know and part of the dream that
surrounds our articulated knowledge has
been extracted as a consequence of us
watching each other and behave and
telling stories about it for thousands
and thousands and thousands of years.
Extracting out patterns of behavior that
characterize humanity and trying to
represent them partly through
invitation,
but also through drama and mythology and
literature and art and all of that to
represent what we're like so that we can
understand what we're like and that
process of understanding is what I see
unfolding,
at least in part the biblical stories
and it's.
It's halting and partial and awkward and
contradictory and and all of that,
which is one of the things that makes
the book so complex,
but I see in it the struggle of humanity
to arise,
to rise above its animal forebear say,
and to become conscious of what it means
to be human.
And that's a very difficult thing
because we don't know who we are,
what we are,
where we came from.
One of those things,
and you know the light life is an
unbroken chain going back three and a
half billion years.
It's an absolutely unbelievable thing.
Every single one of your ancestors
reproduce successfully for three and a
half billion years.
It's absolutely unbelievable.
We rose out of the dirt and the muck and
here we are conscious,
but not knowing and we're trying to
figure out who we are and a story that
we've been telling her,
a set of stories that we've telling for
3000 years seems to me to have something
to offer.
And so when,
when I look at the stories in the Bible,
I do it.
I would say in some sense with a
beginner's mind,
it's,
it's a mystery.
This book,
how the Hell it was made,
why it was made,
why we preserved it,
how it happened to motivated and entire
culture for 2000 years and to transform
the world like what's going on?
How did that happen?
It's by no means obvious and one of the
things that bothers me about casual
critics of religion is that they don't
take the phenomena seriously and it's a
serious phenomenon.
I mean,
I'm not at least because people have the
capacity for religious experience and no
one knows why that is.
I mean you can induce it reliably and
all sorts of different ways.
You could do it with brain stimulation.
You can certainly do it with drugs.
There's especially the psychedelic
variety.
They produce intimations of the divine.
Extraordinarily regularly.
People have been using drugs like that
for God only knows how long,
50,000
years,
maybe more than that,
to produce some sort of intimate union
with the divine.
It's like we don't understand any of
that.
When we discovered the psychedelics in
the late sixties,
it shocked everybody so badly that they
were instantly made illegal and
abandoned in terms of research for like
50 years and it's no wonder because who
the hell would expected that?
Nobody now,
now young was a student of niches.
You see him.
He was also,
I would say at the very astute critic of
Nicha.
He was educated by Freud and Freud.
Freud,
I suppose in some sense started to
collate,
collate the information that we had
pertaining to the notion that people
lived inside a dream.
You know,
it was Freud who really popularized the
idea of the unconscious mind,
and we take this for granted to such a
degree today that we don't understand
how revolutionary the idea was like with
what's happened with Freud is that we've
taken all the marrow out of his bones,
so to speak,
and less the husk behind.
And you know,
now when we think about Freud,
we just think about the husk because
that's everything that's been discarded,
but so much of what he discovered is
part of our popular conception now,
including the idea that your perceptions
and your actions and your thoughts are
all,
um,
what would you say,
informed and shaped by unconscious
motivations that are not part of your
voluntary control.
And that's a very,
very strange thing.
It's one of the most unsettling things
about the psychoanalytic theories
because the psychoanalytic theories are
something like,
you're a loose collection of living
subpersonalities each with its own set
of motivations and perceptions and
emotions and rationales,
all of that.
And you have limited control over that.
So you're like a plurality of,
of,
of internal personalities that's loosely
late into a unity.
You know that because you can't control
yourself very well,
which is one of [inaudible] objections
to niches,
idea that we could create our own values
so young didn't believe that especially
not after interacting with Freud because
he saw that human beings were affected
by things that were deeply,
deeply effected by things that were
beyond their conscious control.
No one really knows how to conceptualize
those things.
You know the cognitive psychologists
think about them in some senses.
Computational machines and the ancient
people,
I think thought of them as gods.
Although it's more complex than that,
like rage would be a god Mars,
the regard of rage.
That's the thing that possesses you when
you're angry,
you know it has a viewpoint and it,
it it,
it says what it wants to say,
and that might have very little to do
with what you want to say when you're
being sensible and it doesn't just
inhabit you.
It inhabits everyone and it lives
forever and it even inhabits animals,
and so it's this transcendent
psychological entity that inhabits the
body politic like,
like a thought and habits.
The brain.
That's one way of thinking about it.
It's a very strange way of thinking,
but it certainly,
it certainly has its merits and so and
those things well in some sense those
are deities,
although it's not that simple and so you
ill was regard very interested in dreams
to started to understand the
relationship between dreams and myths
because he would see in his client's
dreams,
echoes of stories that he knew because
he was deeply read in mythology and and
then he started to believe that the
dream was the birthplace of the myth and
that there was a continual interaction
between the two processes,
the dream and the story and storytelling
and well,
you know,
you tend to tell your dreams as stories
when you remember them and some people
remember dreams all the time,
like two or three a night.
I've had clients like that and they
often have archetipal dreams that have
very clear mythological structures.
I think that's more the case with people
who are creative by the way,
especially if they're a bit unstable at
at the time because the dream tends to
occupy the space of uncertainty and to
concentrate on fleshing out the the
unknown reality.
Before you get a real grip on it,
so it's like the dream is the birthplace
of thinking.
That's a good way of thinking about it,
and so because it's the birthplace of
thinking,
it's not that clear.
It's doing its best to formulate
something that was [inaudible] notion as
opposed to Freud who believed that there
were sensors,
internal sensors that were hiding the
dreams.
True message.
That's not what you and believed.
He believed the dream was doing its best
to excel,
to express a reality that was still
outside of fully articulated conscious
comprehension.
It was [inaudible].
You think,
look,
a thought appears in your head,
right?
That's obvious.
Bang.
It's nothing you ever ask about,
but what the hell does that mean?
A thought appears in your head?
What kind of ridiculous explanation is
that?
You know,
it just doesn't help with anything.
Where does it come from?
Well,
nowhere.
It just appears in my head.
Okay,
well that's not a very sophisticated
explanation as it turns out,
you know,
and so you might think that those
thoughts,
thoughts that you think,
well where do they come from?
Oh,
they're often someone else's thoughts
right?
Someone Long Dad,
that might be part of it,
just like the words you use to think our
utterances of people who've been long
dead and so you're informed by the
spirit of your ancestors.
That's one way of looking at it and your
motivation.
Speak to your motion,
speak to in your body,
speaks to you and it all does all that,
at least in part through the dream.
And the dream is the birthplace of the
fully articulated idea.
They don't just come from nowhere.
Fully fledged,
right?
They have a developmental origin and god
only knows how long.
How lengthy that origin is.
Even to say something like,
I am conscious,
you know,
that's taken chimpanzees.
Don't say that,
you know,
it's been 7 million years since we broke
from chimpanzees,
something like that from the common
ancestor.
You know,
they have no articulated knowledge at
all and very little self representation
in some sense and very little self
consciousness.
And that's not the case with us at all.
And we had to painstakingly figure all
of this out during that,
you know,
7 million year voyage.
And I think some of that's represented.
And,
and,
and captured in some sense in these
ancient stories,
which I believe were part of,
especially the oldest stories in
genesis,
which is the stories we're going to
start with that they were at that,
that some of the archaic nature of the
human being is encapsulated in those
stories and it's very,
very instructive as far as I can tell.
I can give you just a quick example.
You know,
there's an idea of sacrifice in,
in,
in the Old Testament and it's pretty
barbaric.
You know what I mean?
The story of Abraham and Isaac is a good
example of that because Abraham is
called on to actually sacrifice his own
son,
which doesn't really seem like something
that a reasonable God would ask you to
do.
Right.
Then the garden in the Old Testament,
it's frequently cruel and arbitrary and
demanding and paradoxical and which,
which is one of the things that really
gives the book life because it wasn't
edited by a committee or a committee
that was concerned with,
with not offending anyone.
That's for sure.
So,
so young believed that the dream was the
birthplace of thought and I've been
extending that idea because one of the
things I wondered about deeply was,
you know,
you have a dream and then someone
interprets it and you can argue about
whether or not an interpretation is
valid,
just like you can argue about whether
your interpretation of a novel or movie
is valid,
right?
It's a very difficult thing to determine
with any degree of accuracy accounts in
part for the postmodern critique.
But my observation has been that people
will present a dream and sometimes we
can extract out real useful information
from it that the person didn't appear to
know now and they get a flash of
insight.
And to me that's a marker that we
stumbled on something that unites part
of that person that wasn't united
before.
It pulls things together,
which is often what a good story we'll
do where sometimes a good theory,
you know,
things snap together for you and there's
a little light goes on.
And that's one of the markers that I've
used for accuracy and dreams.
And I know in my own family,
uh,
when,
when I was first married,
you know,
I'd have fights with my wife arguments
about this and that and I'm fairly hot
headed and so I'd get all puffed up and
agitated about,
about whatever we were arguing about and
she'd go to sleep,
which was really annoying as so annoying
because I couldn't sleep right.
I like chewing off my fingernails and
she'd be like sleeping peacefully beside
me.
It's maddening.
So,
but often she'd have a dream,
you know,
and then the next morning she discuss it
with me and then we could unravel what
was at the bottom of our argument.
And that was unbelievably useful even
though it was extraordinarily
aggravating.
So,
so,
you know,
I was convinced by young,
it looked to me like his ideas about the
relationship between dreams and
mythology and drama and literature made
sense to me in the and the uh,
and,
and the relationship between that and
art.
I know this native carver,
he's a Kwakwaka'wakw guy.
He's carved a bunch of wooden
sculptures,
totem poles and masks that I have in my
house.
And he's a very interesting person,
not literate,
not particularly literate,
and really still steeped in this ancient
13,000
year old tradition,
these original language speaker and um,
the fact that he isn't literate has sort
of left Camden with the mind of someone
who's preliterate and preliterate people
aren't stupid,
they're just not literate.
So their brains are organized
differently in many ways.
And I've asked him about his,
his,
his intuition for his carvings.
And He's told me that he dreams,
like you've seen the Haida masks,
you know,
what they look like.
Well,
his people are,
are closely related to the hightest,
so it's the same kind of style.
He said he dreams in those animals and,
and can remember his dreams.
And he also talks to his grandparents
who taught him how to carve in his
dreams.
Quite often if he runs into a problem
with carving,
his grandparents will come and he'll
talk to them.
But he sees that the creatures that he's
going to carve living in an animated
sense soon as in his imagination.
And I mean,
it's not that difficult.
First of all,
I have no reason to disbelieve him.
He's a very,
very straightforward person and he
doesn't have the motivation or the guy
all I would say in some sense to invent
a story like that.
There's just no reason that you would
possibly do it.
I don't think he's told that many people
about it.
He thinks it's kinda crazy.
You know?
He said when he was a kid,
he thought he was insane because he'd
had those dreams all the time about
these creatures and so forth and so it
wasn't something he was trumpeting,
but I found it fascinating because I can
see in him of the manifestation of this
unbroken tradition,
we have no idea how traditions like that
are really passed along for thousands
and thousands of years.
Right.
Part of it's oral and memory,
part of it's acted out dramatized and
then part of it's going to be
imaginative and people who aren't
literate,
they store information quite differently
than we do.
We don't remember anything.
It's all written down in books.
Right?
But if you're from an oral culture,
especially if you're trained in that
way,
you have all of that information at
hand,
both so you can speak.
You can tell the stories and you really
know them and you know,
modern people don't really know what
that's like anymore doubt if there's
more than maybe two of you in the
audience that could spout for memory,
like a 30 line poem on poetry was
written so that people could do that,
that,
that that's why we have that form is so
that people could remember it and have
it with them and we don't do any of that
anymore.
Anyways,
back to you and was a great believer in
the dream and I noted that dreams will
tell you things that you don't know and
then I thought,
well,
how the hell can that be?
How in the world can something you think
up tell you something you don't know?
How does that make any sense?
First of all,
why don't you understand it?
Why does it have to come forth in the
form of the dream?
It's like you're not.
There's something going on inside you
that you don't control rights.
The dream happens.
Do you just like life happens to you.
I mean,
there is the odd lucid dreamer who can,
you know,
apply a certain amount of conscious
control,
but most of the time it's you're laying
there asleep and it's crazy complicated.
World manifests itself inside you and
you don't know how you couldn't.
You can't do it when you're awake and
you don't know what it means.
It's like what the hell is going on?
And that's one of the things that's so
damn frightening about the
psychoanalysts because you get this both
from Freud and young.
You really start to understand that
there are things inside you that are
happening that control you instead of
the other way around.
You know,
there's a bit of reciprocal control,
but there's manifestations of spirits,
so to speak inside you that determine
the manner in which you walk through
life and you don't control it.
And what does is it random.
You know,
there are people who have claimed that
dreams are mirror merely the consequence
of random neuronal firing,
which is a theory I think is absolutely
absurd because there's nothing random
about dreams.
You know,
there are very,
very structured and very,
very complex and they're not like snow
on a television screen or or static on a
radio like those things are complicated
and and then also I've seen so often
that people have very coherent dreams
that have a perfect narrative structure.
Now they're fully developed in some
sense and so that just doesn't hide,
that theory just doesn't go anywhere
with me.
I just can't see that as useful at all
and so,
so I'm more likely to take the phenomena
seriously say,
well,
there's something to dreams what you
dream of the future,
and then you try to make it into a
reality that seems to be an important
thing,
or maybe you dream up a nightmare and
try to make that into a reality because
people do that too.
If they're hell bent on revenge,
for example,
and full of hatred and resentment,
that manifests itself and terrible
fantasies,
you know,
those are dreams.
Then people go act them out.
These things are powerful,
you know,
and whole nations can get caught up in
collective dreams.
That's what happened to the Nazis.
That's what happened to Nazi Germany in
the 19 thirties and it was absolutely
remarkable,
amazing,
horrific destructive spectacle.
And the same thing happened in the
Soviet Union.
The same thing happened in China.
It's like we have to take these things
seriously,
you know,
and try to understand what's going on.
So you believe that the dream could
contain more information than was yet
articulated.
You think artists do the same thing,
you know,
like people go to museums and they look
at paintings,
renaissance paintings or modern
paintings and they don't exactly know
why they're there.
Now I was in this room and in New York,
I don't remember which museum,
but he was a room full of renaissance
art,
you know,
great painters,
the greatest painters and thought maybe
that room was worth a billion dollars or
something outrageous because there were
like 20 paintings in there,
you know,
so priceless.
And the first thing is,
well,
why are those paintings worth so much
and why is there a museum in the biggest
city in the world devoted to them?
And why do people from all over the
world come and look at them?
What the hell are those people doing?
One of them was of the assumption of
Mary,
you know,
beautifully painted,
absolutely glowing work of art and
there's like 20 people standing in front
of it looking at it and think,
what are those people up to?
You know,
they don't know.
Why did they make a pilgrimage to New
York to come and look at that painting?
It's not like they know why is it worth
so much?
I mean,
I know there's a status element to it
too,
but that begs the question,
why did those items become such high
status items?
What is it about them that so absolutely
remarkable?
Well,
we're strange creatures,
so I was trying to figure out in part,
well where did the information that's in
the dream come from?
It has to come from somewhere and you
can think about it as a revelation,
you know,
because it's,
it's like it springs out of the void and
it's new knowledge and it's a revelation
you didn't produce it,
it just,
it just appears.
But that's one of the things I want to
do with this series.
It's like I am scientifically minded and
I'm quite a rational person and I like
to have an explanation for things that's
rational and empirical before I look for
any other kind of explanation and I
don't want to say that everything that's
associated with divinity can be reduced
in some manner to biology or to an
evolutionary history or anything like
that,
but in so far as it's possible to do
that reduction,
I'm going to do that and I'm going to
leave the other phenomena floating in
the air because they can't be pinned
down and in that category I would put
the category of mystical or religious
experience,
which we don't understand at all.
So
artists observe one another.
They observe and they represent what
they see and they transmit a message of
what they see to us and they teach us to
see and we don't necessarily know what
it is that we're learning from them,
but we're learning something or at least
we're acting like we're learning
something.
We go to movies,
we watch stories.
We,
we,
we immerse ourselves in fiction
constantly.
That's an artistic production and for
many people,
the world of the arts is a living world
and that's particularly true if you're a
creative person.
It's the creative artistic people that
do move the knowledge of humanity
forward and they do that with their
artistic productions.
First.
They're on the edge and the dancers do
that and the poets do that and the
visual artists do that at the musicians
do that and we're not sure what they're
doing.
We're not sure what musicians are doing,
what the hell are they doing?
Why do you like music?
You know,
it gives you a deep intimation of the
significance of things and no one
questions that you go to a concert,
you're thrilled.
It's a quasi religious experience,
particularly if the people really get
themselves together and get the crowd
moving.
You know,
there's something incredibly intense
about it,
but it makes no sense whatsoever.
It's,
it's not an easy thing to understand.
Music is deeply patterned and and,
and,
and patterned in layers and I think that
has something to do with it because
reality is patterned and deeply
patterned in layers.
And so I think music is representing
reality in some fundamental way and that
we get into the sway of that and sort of
participate in being.
And that's part of what makes it such an
uplifting experience.
But we don't really know that's what
we're doing.
We just go do it.
And,
and,
and it's nourishing for people,
right?
I mean,
young people in particular that lots of
them live for music.
It's where they derive all their
meaning,
their cultural identity.
Everything that's nourishing comes from
their affiliation with their music that
is part of their cultural identity.
So that's an amazing thing.
The question still remains,
where does the information and dreams
come from?
And I think what it,
where it comes from is that we watch the
patterns that everyone.
So we've watched that forever and we've
got some representations of those
patterns.
That's part of our cultural history.
That's what's embedded in stories,
in fictional accounts of the story
between good and evil.
The bad guy and the good guy and the
romance,
you know,
these are,
these are canonical patterns of being
for people in and they deeply affect
this because they represent what it is
that we will act out in the world and
then we flesh that out with the
individual information we have about
ourselves and other people and so it's
like there's a,
there's a,
there's waves of,
of behavioral patterns that manifest
themselves in the crowd across time that
great dramas are played on the crowd
across time and the artists watched that
and they get intimations of what that is
and they write it down and they tell us
and then we're a little clearer about
what we're up to now.
Like a great dramatists like Shakespeare
let's say is we know that what he wrote
is fiction and then we say,
well,
fiction isn't true,
but then you think,
well wait a minute.
Maybe it's true.
Like numbers are true.
You know,
numbers are an abstraction from the
underlying reality,
but no one in their right mind would
really think numbers aren't true.
You could even make a case that the
numbers are more real than the things
that they represent,
right?
Because the abstraction is so insanely
powerful.
Once you have mathematics,
you're just deadly.
You can move the world with mathematics
and so it's not obvious that the
abstraction is less real than the than
the than the more concrete reality and
you take a work of fiction like hamlet
and you think,
well,
is that it's not true because it's
fiction,
but then you think,
wait a minute.
What kind of explanation is that?
Like maybe it's more true than
nonfiction because it takes what the
story that needs to be told about you
and the story that needs to be told
about you and you and you and you and
abstracts that out and says,
look,
here's something that's a key part of
the human experience as such.
Right?
So it's.
It's an abstraction from this underlying
noisy substrate and people are affected
by it because they see that the thing
that's represented the as part of the
pattern of their being,
that's the right way to think about it.
And then with these old stories,
these ancient stories,
it seems to me like that process has
been occurring for thousands of years.
It's like we watched ourselves and we
extracted out some stories,
we imitated each other and we
represented that in drama and then we
distilled the drama and we got a
representation of the distillation and
then we did it again.
And at the end of that process that
took,
God only knows how long.
I think some of these stories,
they've traced fairytales back 10,000
years,
some fairy tales in relatively unchanged
for.
And it certainly seems to me that the
archeological evidence,
for example,
suggests that the really old stories
that,
that the Bible begins with our,
at least that old and likely embedded in
a prehistory that's far older than that,
you might think,
well,
how can you be so sure?
The answer to that in part is that
cultures that don't change,
like the ancient cultures,
right?
They didn't change as fast as they
stayed the same.
That's the answer.
So they call it,
they keep their information moving
generation to generation.
That's how they stay the same.
And so we know,
again,
in the archaeological record,
there are records of rituals that have
remained relatively unbroken for up to
20,000
years.
It was discovered in caves in Japan that
were set up for a particular kind of
bare worship that was also
characteristic of western Europe.
So these things can last for very long
periods of time.
We're watching each other act in the
world,
and then the question is,
well,
how long have we been watching each
other?
And the answered that in some senses,
while as long as there's been creatures
with nervous systems now that's a long
time,
you know,
that's some hundreds of millions of
years,
perhaps longer than that.
We've been watching each other trying to
figure out what we're up to across that
entire span of time and some of that
knowledge is built right into our
bodies,
which is why we can dance with each
other,
for example.
Right?
Because understanding isn't just
something that you,
that you have as an abstraction,
it's something that you act out.
No,
that's what children are doing when
they're learning too rough and tumble
play is they're learning to integrate
their body with the body of someone else
in a harmonious way,
learning to cooperate and compete,
and that's all instantiated right into
their body.
It's not abstract knowledge.
They don't know that they're doing that.
They're just doing it and so we can even
use our body as a representational
platform,
so we'd been studying each other for a
long time.
Abstracting out what is it that we're up
to and that's that.
That's what we're up to.
What should we be up to?
That's even a more fundamental question.
If you're going to live in the world and
you're going to do it properly,
what does properly mean and how is it
that you might go about that?
Well,
it.
It's the right question,
right?
It's what everyone wants to know.
How do you live in the world?
Not what is the world made of.
It's not the same question.
How do you live in the world?
It's the eternal question of human
beings and I guess we're the only
species that has ever really asked that
question because all the other animals,
they just go and do whatever they do,
not us.
It's a question for us.
We've had to.
We have to become aware of it.
We have to be able to speak it.
God only knows why,
but that seems to be the situation.
So we act that acting is shaped by the
world,
that acting is shaped by society into
something that we don't understand,
but that we can model,
that we can model it.
We model it in our stories.
We Marlett with our bodies and that's
where the dream gets its information.
The dream is part of the process that's
watching everything and then trying to
formulate it and trying to say,
well,
trying to get the signal from the noise
and to portray it in dramatic form
because a dream is a little drama and
then you get the chance to talk about
what that dream is and then you have.
You have something like articulated
knowledge at that point.
And so the Bible I would say is,
is it sort of exists in that space
that's half into the dream and half into
articulated knowledge.
It's something like that and going into
it to find out what the stories are
about can,
what can,
what can aid our self understanding.
And then the other issue is,
is that if nature was correct and if
Dostoevsky or young was correct and
Dostoevsky as well,
we without the cornerstone that that
understanding provides,
were lost.
And that's not good because then we're
susceptible to psych pathology.
That's psychological pathology.
You know,
the people who are ad adamant,
anti religious thinkers seem to believe
that if we abandoned our immersement in
the underlying dream,
that
we'd all instantly become rationalist
like descartes or Bacon or,
you know,
intelligent,
clear thinking,
rational scientific people.
I don't believe that for a moment
because I don't think there's any
evidence for it.
I think we would become so irrational so
rapidly that the weirdest mysteries of
the Catholicism would see positively
rational by contrast.
And I think that's already happening.
So.
Okay,
so this is the idea.
Essentially,
you know that you have the unknown world
at.
That's just what you don't know at all.
That's,
that's outside,
that's the ocean that surrounds the
island,
that you inhabit something like that.
It's chaos itself and then you act in
that world and you act in ways you don't
understand.
There's more to your actions.
Then you can understand.
One of the things young said,
I love this.
When I first understood it,
he said,
everybody acts out of myth,
but very few people know what their myth
is and you should know what your myth is
because it might be a tragedy and maybe
you don't want it to be,
and that's really worth thinking because
thinking about,
because you're.
You have a pattern of behavior that
characterized as you know,
when God only knows where you got it.
Partly it's biological.
Partly it's from your parents.
It's,
it's your unconscious assumptions.
It's the way the philosophy of your
society is shaped you and is.
It's aimed.
It's aiming you somewhere.
Well,
is it aiming you somewhere you want to
go?
That's a good question.
That's part of self realization.
You know,
we know we don't understand our actions.
That's almost every argument you have
with someone is about that.
It's like,
why did you do that?
You come up with some half baked reasons
why you did it.
You're flailing around in the darkness.
You know,
you try to give an account for yourself,
but you can only do it partially.
It's very,
very difficult because you're in your,
you're a complicated animal with the
beginnings of an articulated mind,
something like that.
And you're just way more than you can
handle it.
And
Alright,
so you act things out,
right?
You,
you act things out and that's a kind of
competence.
And then you imagine what you act out
and you imagine what everyone else acts
out and so there's a tremendous amount
of information in your action and then
that information is translated up into
the dream and into art,
into mythology and literature.
And there's a tremendous amount of
information in that.
And then some of that is translated into
articulated thought.
And I'll give you a quick example of
something like that.
I think this is partly what happens in
exodus when Moses comes up with the law,
you know,
he's wandering around with the
Israelites forever in the desert and
are,
they're like going left and going right
worshiping idols and like having a hell
of a time and um,
you know,
getting rebellious and Moses goes up on
the mountain and he has this tremendous
revelation sort of in the sight of God
and illuminates him and he comes down
with the law.
You think,
well,
you know,
Moses acted as a judge.
I know this is a mythological story.
Moses acted as a judge in the desert.
He was continually mediating between
people who are having problems
constantly trying to keep peace.
And so what are you doing when you're
trying to keep peace?
As you're trying to understand what
peace is,
right?
You have to apply the principles,
but what are the principles?
But you don't know the principals or
whatever satisfies people enough to make
peace.
And maybe you do that 10,000
times and then you get some sense of,
Oh,
here's the principles that bring peace
and then one day at blasts into your
consciousness,
like,
like a revelation,
here's the rules that were already
acting out.
Well that's the 10 commandments.
It's,
they're there to begin with and Moses
comes forward and says,
look,
this is already basically what we're
doing.
But now it's codafide.
Right?
And like that's all historical process
that's condensed into a single story.
But obviously that happened because we
have written law,
right?
And that emerged in good legal systems
that emerges from the bottom up.
That's English.
Common law is exactly like that,
right?
It's single decisions that are
predicated on principles that have been
articulated and made into the body of
law.
And the body of law is something you act
out.
That's why it's a body of law.
If you're a good citizen,
you act out the body of law and the body
of law has principles.
Okay?
So the question is,
there's principles that guide our
behavior.
What are those principles?
Well,
I think when you,
if you're,
if you want the initial answer of what
the art archaic Israelites meant by God,
that something like what they meant now,
it's not a good enough explanation,
but look,
imagine that you,
that you have,
that you're a chimpanzee and you have a
powerful,
uh,
a dominant figure at the pinnacle of
your society that,
that represents power.
Now,
more than that because it's not sheer
physical prowess that keeps a chimp at
the top of the hierarchy,
it's much more complicated than that.
But you could say,
well,
there's,
there's a principle that a dominant
person manifests,
and then you might say,
well,
that principals shines forth even more
brightly.
If you know 10 people who are dominant,
powerful,
then you can extract out what dominance
means from that.
You can extract out what power means
from that and then you can divorce the
concept from the people.
And we had to do that at some point
because we can save power in a human
context and we can imagine what that
means,
but it's divorced from any specific
manifestation of power.
Well,
how the hell did we do that?
Like that's so complicated when if
you're a chimp,
the power is in another chimp.
It's not some damn abstraction.
Well,
so the.
So the question is think,
think about it when we're in these
hierarchies,
many of them across centuries,
we're trying to figure out what the
guiding principle is.
We're trying to extract out the core of
the guiding principle and we turned that
into a representation
of a pattern of being well.
It's something like that.
That's God.
It's an abstracted ideal and it's.
It's,
it's put in persona.
Find form manifests itself in
personified form,
but that's okay because what we're
trying to get at is the,
in some sense,
the essence of what it means to be a
properly functioning and properly a
properly functioning properly social and
property competent individual.
We're trying to figure out what that
means.
You need a an embodiment.
You need an ideal that's abstracted that
you could act out that would enable you
to understand what that means and that's
what we've been driving out.
So that's the first hypothesis.
In some sense.
I'm going to go over some of the some of
the attributes of this abstract,
that ideal that we've formalized as God,
but that's the first sort of hypothesis
is that a philosophical or moral ideal
manifests itself first as a concrete
pattern of behavior that's
characteristic of a single individual
and then it's a set of individuals and
then it's an abstraction from that set
and then you have the abstraction and so
important.
So here's a political implication.
For example,
one of the debates we might say between
early Christianity and the late Roman
empire was whether or not an emperor
could be God literally right to be
deified,
to put enough to be put in a temple and
you can see why that might happen
because that's someone at the pinnacle
of a very steep hierarchy who has a
tremendous amount of power and
influence.
But the Christian response to that was
never confuse the specific sovereign
with the principle of sovereignty
itself.
It's brilliant to see,
see how difficult it is to come up with
an idea like that so that even the
person who has the power is actually
subordinate to something else
subordinate to,
let's call it a divine principle,
for lack of a better word,
so even the king himself is subordinate
to the principal and we still believe
that because we believe that our
president or prime minister is
subordinate to the damn law.
Whatever the body of law,
right?
There's a principle inside that that
even the leader is subordinate to and
without that,
and you could argue we can't even have a
civilized society because your.
Your leader immediately turns into
something that's transcendent and all
powerful and I mean that's certainly
what happened in the Soviet Union and
what happened in Maoist China and what
happened in Nazi Germany because there
was nothing for the powerful to
subordinate themselves to.
You're supposed to be subordinate to
God.
So what does that mean?
Well,
we're going to tear that idea part,
but partly what it means is that your
subordinate,
even if you're sovereign to the
principle of sovereignty itself,
and then the question is what the hell
is the principle of sovereignty?
And I could say we been working that out
for a very long period of time,
and so that's one of the things that
we'll talk about because the ancient
Mesopotamians and the ancient Egyptians
had some very interesting dramatic ideas
about that.
So is,
for example,
very briefly,
there was a dandy known as Marduk and
Martech.
He was in Mesopotamia.
Daddy,
and imagine this is sorta what happened
is that as an empire grew out of the
post ice age age,
say 15,000
years ago,
10,000
all these tribes came together in these
tribes.
Each had their own data,
their own image of the ideal,
but then they started to occupy the same
territory,
right?
And so then one tribe had god,
a in one tribe had God be and no one
could wipe the other one out and then it
would just be God a who wins.
But that's not so good because while
maybe you want to trade with those
people or maybe you don't want to lose
half your population in a war or
something like that,
so then you have to have an argument
about whose God is going to take
priority,
which ideal is going to take priority
and what seems to happen is that's
represented in mythology is a battle of
the gods in sort of celestial space,
but from a practical perspective,
it's more like an ongoing dialogue.
You believe this,
I believe this.
You believe that,
How are we going to Meld that together?
So you take God a and you take God be
and maybe what you do is extract God,
see from them and you say,
well God see now has the attributes of a
and B,
and then some other tribes come in and
then see takes them over to.
And so you get like with Marduk for
example,
he has a multitude of names,
50 different names.
While those are names,
at least in part of the subordinate,
God's that represented the tribes that
came together to make the civilization.
That's part of the process by which that
abstract,
that ideal is abstractive.
You think this is important and it works
because you're trying to lie,
but you think this is important and it
works because your tribe is alive and so
we'll take the best of both.
If we could manage it and extract,
extract out something that's even more
abstract that covers both of us.
If we can do it.
One of the things that's really
interesting about,
I'll just give you a couple of of his
features,
but he has eyes all the way around his
head.
He's elected by all the other gods to be
Katen God.
So that's the first thing that's quite
cool and they elect him because they're
facing a terrible threat,
sort of like a flood and a monster
combined,
something like that.
And Martin basically says that if they
elect him,
top God,
then he'll go out and stop the flood
monster and they won't all get wiped
out.
It's a serious threat.
It's chaos itself,
making its comeback.
And so all the gods agree and Martin has
the new manifestation.
He's got eyes all the way around his
head and he speaks magic words,
and then he also goes out and when he
fights,
he fights this deity called Tiamat and
we need to know that because the word
Taya,
Matt is associated with the Word Tay.
Home t h o m
entail is the chaos that God makes order
out of at the beginning of time in
genesis.
So it's linked very tightly to the story
and Martin with his eyes and his
capacity to speak.
Magic words goes out to confront tie.
Matt,
who's like a watery sea dragon,
something like that.
It's a classic.
It's a classic St George Story.
Go out and and recalc on the Dragon.
He cuts her into pieces and he makes the
world out of her pieces and that's the
world that human beings live in.
The Mesopotamian emperor acted out
Marduk.
He was allowed to be emperor in so far
as he was a good Marduk console.
That meant that he had eyes all the way
around his head and he could speak
magic.
He could speak properly and so that
we're starting to understand they're at
that point,
the essence of leadership,
right?
Because what's leadership?
It's the capacity to see what the hell
is in front of your face and maybe in
every direction and then the capacity to
use your language properly in a
transformative manner and to transform
chaos into order and God only know how
those,
how long it took the Mesopotamians to
figure that out,
and the best they could do is dramatize
it,
but it's staggeringly brilliant.
No,
it's.
It's by no means obvious in this chaos
is chaos is a very strange thing and
this is the chaos that God wrestled with
at the beginning of time.
Chaos is what it.
It's half psychological and half real.
There's no other way to really describe
it.
The chaos is what you encounter when
you're thrown into deep confusion,
right?
When your world falls apart,
when when you encounter something that
blows you into pieces,
when your dreams die,
when you're betrayed,
it's the chaos that emerges and the
chaos is everything at once and it's too
much for you and that's for sure,
and it pulls you down into the
underworld and all.
That's where the dragons are and all
you've got at that point is your
capacity to bloody well keep your eyes
open and to speak as carefully and
clearly as you can and maybe if you're
lucky,
you'll get through it that way and come
out the other side and it's taken people
a very long time to figure that out.
And it looks to me like the idea is
erected on the platform of our ancient
ancestors maybe tens of millions of
years ago because we seem to represent
that which disturbs us deeply using the
same system that we use to represent
like serpentine while serpentine or
other carnivorous predators and it,
you know,
we're biological creatures,
right?
So when we've formulated our capacity to
abstract are strange capacity to
abstract and use language,
we still have all those underlying
systems that were there when we were
only animals and we have to use those
systems there.
They're part of the emotional and
motivational architecture of our
thinking and part of the reason we can
demonize our enemies who upset or axioms
is because we perceive them as if
they're carnivorous predators.
We do it with the same system and that's
chaos itself.
The thing that always threatens us,
right?
The snakes that came to the trees,
we lived in them like 60 million years
ago.
It's the same damn systems.
So the Martech story is partly the story
of using attention to language to
confront those things that most
threatened us and some of those things
are real,
real world threats,
but some of them are psychological
threats which are just as profound but
far more abstract,
but we use the same systems to represent
them.
It's why you freeze.
If you're frightened,
right?
You're a prey animal.
You're like a rabbit,
you've seen us,
you've seen something that's going to
eat you,
you freeze.
And that way you're paralyzed,
you're turn to stone,
which is what you do when you see a
medusa with a head full of state snakes,
right?
Your turned to stone,
you're paralyzed,
and the reason you do that is because
you're using the Predator detection
system to protect yourself.
Your heart rate goes way up and you get
ready to move.
Things that upset us,
rely on that system,
and then the story.
The story for example,
is the idea that if there are things
that upset you,
chaotic,
terrible,
serpentine,
monstrous underworld,
things that threaten you,
the best thing to do is to open your
eyes and get your speech organized and
go out and confront the thing and make
the world out of it.
And it's staggering.
When I,
when I read that story and started to
understand,
it just blew me away.
It's such a profound idea,
and we know it's true too,
because we know in psychotherapy for
example,
that you're much better off to confront
your fears head on.
Then you are to wait and let them find
you.
And so partly what you do if you're a
psychotherapist,
is you help people break their fears
into little pieces,
the things that upset them and into
encounter them one by one and master
that when you're teaching this process
of eternal mastery over the strange and
chaotic world and that all of that makes
up some of the background.
We haven't even got to the first
sentence of the biblical stories yet.
Good.
And all of that makes up the background.
So you have to think that we've
extracted this story.
These are this strange collection of
stories with all its errors and it's and
it's repetitions and its peculiarities
out of the entire.
Like the entire history that we've been
able to collect ideas and it's the best
we've been able to do.
And I know there are other religious
traditions about not concerned about
that at the moment because we can use
this as an example,
but it's the basket we've been able to
do.
And what I'm hoping is that we can
return to the stories in some sense with
an open mind and see if there's
something there that we actually need.
And hope and I hope that that will be
the case and as I said,
all approaches as rationally as I
possibly can,
so well this is the idea to begin with,
you know,
we have the unknown as such,
and then we act in it like animals act,
they act first,
they don't think,
they don't imagine they act and that's,
that's where we started.
We started acting and then we started to
be able to represent how we acted and
then we started to talk about how we
represented how we acted and that
enabled us to tell stories because that
is what a story is.
It's to tell about how you represent how
you act and so you know that because if
you read a book,
what happens?
You read the board and images come to
mind of the people in the book behaving,
right?
It's one step from acting it out.
It's you don't act it out cause you can
abstract.
You can represent action without having
to act it out.
It's amazing thing and that's part of
the development of the prefrontal
cortex.
It's part of the capacity for human
abstract thought is that you can pull
the behavior,
the representation of the behavior away
from the behavior and manipulate the
representation before you enact it.
That's why you think it's so that you
can generate a pattern of action and
tested out in a fictional world before
you embody it and die because you're
foolish,
right?
You let the representation die,
not you,
and that's why you think.
And so that's partly what we're trying
to do with these stories.
What do I hope to accomplish?
I hope to end this 12 lecture series
knowing more than I did when I started.
That's my goal because I said,
you know,
I'm not telling you what I know.
I'm trying to figure things out.
And,
and,
and this is part of this is part of the
process by which I'm doing that.
And so I'm doing my best to think on my
feet.
You know,
what?
I'm going to come prepared.
But I'm trying to stay on the edge of my
capacity to generate knowledge and to
make this continually clearer and to get
to the bottom of things.
And so I'm hoping that that's what I'm,
that's what I want to accomplish and it
seems like people are interested in
that.
So then we're going to try to accomplish
that together.
And so that's the,
that's the plan and the idea is to see
if there's something at the bottom of
this amazing civilization that we've
managed to construct
did I think is in peril for a variety of
reasons and maybe if we understand it a
little bit,
little bit better,
we won't be so prone just to throw the
damn thing away,
which I think would be a big mistake.
And to throw it away because of
resentment and hatred and bitterness and
historical ignorance and jealousy and,
and,
and the desire for destruction and all
of that.
It's like I don't want to go there,
it's a bad idea to go there and we need
to be grounded better.
And so hopefully.
Well we'll see how this works.
Alright.
So how do I approach this?
Well,
first of all,
I think in evolutionary terms,
as far as I'm concerned,
the cosmos is 15 billion years old and
the world is four and a half billion
years old and there's been life for
three and a half billion years and there
were,
you know,
there were,
there were creatures that had pretty
developed nervous systems 300 to 600
million years ago and we living in trees
as small mammals 60 million years ago
when we were down on the plains between
$60 million and 7 million years ago.
And that's about when we split from
chimpanzees and modern human beings seem
to emerge about 150,000
years ago and civilization pretty much
after the last ice age.
Something after 15,000
years ago,
not very long ago at all.
You know?
And that's the.
That's the span across which I want to
understand.
I want to understand why we are the way
we are looking at life and it's in its
continual complexity right from the
beginning of life itself.
And there's some real utility in that
because we share attributes with other
animals,
even apple,
apple animals,
as simple as crustaceans,
for example,
have nervous system properties that are
very much like ours.
And it's very much worth worth knowing
that.
So I think in an evolutionary way,
I think it's a grand and remarkable way
to think because it has this incredible
timespan,
right?
It's this amazing.
I mean,
people at the end of the 19th century,
middle of the 19th century say,
thought the world really thought the
world was about 6,000
years old.
I mean 15 billion years old.
That's a lot more,
right?
It's a lot grander.
It's a lot bigger,
but it's also a lot more frightening and
an alienating in some sense because,
you know,
the cosmos has become so vast.
It's either easy for human beings to
think of themselves as trivial specs on
a trivial spec out some misbegotten hell
hole end of the galaxy among hundreds of
millions of galaxies,
right?
It's,
it's very easy to see yourself as
nothing in that span of time.
That's a real challenge for people.
And um,
I think it's a mistake to think that way
because I think consciousness is far
more than we think it is,
but it's still something we have to
grapple with.
I'm a psychoanalytic thinker,
and what that means is that I believe
that people are collections of
subpersonalities.
Those subpersonalities are alive.
They're not machines.
They're there.
They have their viewpoint,
they have their wants,
they have their perceptions,
they have their arguments,
they have their emotions.
They're like low resolution
representations of you.
You know,
when you get angry,
it's like it's a very low resolution
representation of you.
It only wants rage or it only wants
something to eat or when we want it,
only wants water,
only wants sex.
It's,
it's,
it's you,
but shrunken,
focused in a specific direction.
And,
and,
and those,
all those motivational systems are very,
very ancient,
very archaic,
and very,
very powerful.
And they blamed determining role in the
manner in which we manifest ourselves.
As Freud pointed out with the Ed,
we have to figure out how to take all
those underlying animalistic motivations
and emotions and civilize them in some
way so that we can all live in the same
general territory without tearing each
other to shreds,
which is maybe the position of both
chimpanzee and humanity.
So,
so I take that seriously.
The idea that we're a loose collection
of spirits and that,
that,
that no,
it says in the Old Testament somewhere
that the fear of God is the beginning of
wisdom and I think this is akin to that.
If you know that you're not in control
of yourself thoroughly and that there
are other factors behind the scenes,
like the Greeks thought that human
beings were the play things of the gods
outs,
the way they conceptualize the world.
They sort of meant the same thing.
They meant that there are these great
forces that move us,
that we don't create that were,
that were,
that were subordinate to in some sense,
not entirely,
but we can be subordinate to them and
they move our destinies.
That was the Greek view and there's
something.
It,
it,
it teaches you humility to understand
that,
that there's a hell of a lot more going
on behind the scenes and you're,
you're the driver of a very complex
vehicle,
but you don't understand the vehicle
very well and it's got its own
motivations and methods and sometimes
you think it's doing something and it's
doing something completely,
completely different.
You see that in psychotherapy all the
time because you know you helped someone
unwind a pattern of behavior that
they've manifested forever.
First of all,
they describe it.
Then they become aware of it.
Then maybe they start to see what the
cause is.
They have no idea why they were acting
like that.
You know,
they have to have the memory that
produced the,
the behavioral pattern to begin with.
It has to be brought back to mind and
then it has to be analyzed and assessed
and then they have to think about a
different way of acting.
And it's extraordinarily complex.
So
psychoanalytic literary,
well
there's this new,
there's this postmodern idea about
literature and about the world for that
matter that if you take a complex piece
of literature like,
like a Shakespeare play,
there's no end to the number of
interpretations that you can make of it.
You know,
you can eat turpin each word.
You can interpret each phrase,
each sentence,
each paragraph,
you can interpret the entire play.
The way you interpreted depends on how
many other books you've read,
depends on your orientation in the
world.
It depends on a very,
very large number of things,
how cultured you are or how how much
culture you lack.
All of those things.
That opens up a huge,
a huge vista for potential
interpretation and so the postmodern and
sort of stubbed their toe on that
thought,
well,
if there's this vast number of
interpretations of any particular
literary work,
how can you be sure that any
interpretation is more valid than any
other interpretation?
And if you can't be sure,
then how do you even know those are
great works.
How do you know they can't?
Maybe they're just works that the people
in power have used to facilitate their
continual succession of power,
which is really a postmodern idea.
Very,
very cynical one,
but it has its point,
but the thing is it's grounded in
something real,
right?
It's like,
yes,
you can interpret things forever.
I want to show you something here.
Just briefly.
We'll go back to it later.
Look at this.
This is the cool one of the coolest
things I've ever seen.
So at the bottom here,
every single one of those lines is a
biblical verse.
Okay?
Now the length of the line is
proportionate to how many times that
verse is referred to in some way by some
other verse.
So you say,
well,
this is the first hyperlinked book,
right?
I'm dead serious about that.
Like that.
You can't click and get the hyperlinks
obviously,
but it's a thoroughly hyperlink book and
it's because,
well,
the people who worked on these stories
that are hypothetically at the end,
right,
which is the end,
can't affect the beginning.
That's the rule of time,
right?
What happens now can affect what
happened to you 10 years ago.
Even though it actually can,
but whatever.
Well,
you reinterpret things right and then
they're not the same but like whatever,
we won't get into that,
but technically speaking the president
cannot affect the past,
but if we're looking at a piece of
literature that's not right because when
you write the end,
you know what it was at the beginning
and when you write the beginning or edit
it,
you know what's at the end so you can
weave the whole thing together and
there's 65,000
cross-references and that's what this
map shows and so that's a great visual
representation of the book and then you
can see,
well why is it deep?
Why is the book deep?
Well,
just imagine how many pathways you can
take through that,
right?
I mean you'd just journey through your
journey through that forever.
You'd never ever get to the end of it.
There's permutations and combinations
and every phrase is dependent on every
other phrase in every versus dependent
on every other doctor.
Not entirely,
but 65,000
is not a bad start and so.
Okay,
well so,
so the that that's another issue in some
sense that seems to make the
postmodernist critique even more.
Correct.
How in the world you're going to extract
out a canonical interpretation of
something like that,
so like it's not possible,
but here's the issue as far as I can
tell,
the interpreter.
So in the postmodernists extended that
critique to the world,
they said,
look,
well a text is complicated enough.
You can't extract out a canonical
interpretation.
What about the world?
The world is way more complicated than a
text,
and so there's an infinite number of
ways that you can look at the world and
so how do we know that any one way is
better than any other way?
And that's a good question.
Now the postmodern answer was we can't,
and that's not a good answer because you
drowned in chaos under those
circumstances,
right?
You can't make sense of anything and
that's not good because
it's not neutral to not make sense of
things.
It's very anxiety provoking.
It's very depressing because if things
are so chaotic that you can't get a
handle on them,
your body defaults into emergency
preparation mode and your heart rate
goes up and your immune system stops
working and like you burn yourself,
you age rapidly because you're
surrounded by nothing you can control.
It's varying.
That's an existential crisis,
right?
It's anxiety provoking in depressing,
very hard on people and even more than
that,
it turns out that the way that we're
constructed neurophysiologically is that
we don't experience any positive emotion
unless we have an aim and we can see
ourselves progressing towards that aim.
It isn't precisely attaining the aim
that makes us happy.
As you all know,
if you've ever attained anything because
soon as you obtain it,
then the whole little game ends,
then you have to come up with another
game,
right?
So it's sisyphus and that's okay,
but,
but it does show that the attainment
can't be the thing that drives you
because it collapses the game.
That's what happens when you graduate
from university.
It's like you're king of the mountain
for one day and then you're like surf at
at,
at starbucks for the next five years.
So what happens is that that human
beings are weird creatures because we're
much more activated by having an aim and
moving towards it than we are by
attainment.
And what that means is you have to have
an aim and that means you have to have
an interpretation and it also means that
the nobler aim.
That's one way of thinking about it,
the better your life.
And that's a really interesting thing to
know because you know,
you've heard ever since you were tiny
that you should act like a good person.
You shouldn't lie,
for example,
and you might think,
well,
why the hell should I act like a good
person?
Why not lie in even a three year old can
ask that question because smart,
smart kids learn to lie earlier by the
way,
and they think,
well,
why not twist the fabric of reality so
that it serves your specific short term
needs?
I mean,
that's a great question.
Why not do that?
Why Act Morally?
If you can get away with something and
it brings you closer to something you
want,
well why not do it?
These are good questions.
It's not self evident.
Well,
it seems to be tied in with what I just
mentioned.
It's like your destabilize yourself and
things become chaotic.
That's not good,
and if you don't have a no blame,
then you have nothing but but shallow or
trivial pleasures and they don't sustain
you and that's not good because because
life is so difficult,
so much,
it's so much suffering.
It's so complex.
It ends and everyone dies and it's
painful.
It's like without a no blame,
how can you withstand any of that?
You can't.
You become desperate and once you become
desperate things go.
Things go from bad to worse,
very rapidly when you become desperate,
and so there's the idea of the noble aim
and it's.
It's not something.
It's something that's necessary.
It's the bread that people cannot live
without,
right?
That's not physical bread.
It's the noble aim and what is that?
Well,
it was encapsulated in part in the story
of Marduk.
That's,
that's to pay attention.
It's to speak properly.
It's to confront chaos,
it's to make a better world.
It's something like that,
and that's enough of a no blame so that
you can stand up without cringing at the
very thought of your own existence so
that you can do something that's
worthwhile to justify your wretched
position on the planet.
So now there's a literary issue.
Is that so look,
you take a text,
you can interpret it a variety of ways,
but that's not right.
This is where the postmodernist went
wrong because what you're looking for in
a text and in the world for that matter
is is sufficient order and direction,
so then we have to think,
well,
what is sufficient order and direction
means well,
you don't want to suffer so much that
your life is unbearable.
Right?
That just seems self evident.
Pain argues for itself,
I think of pain as the fundamental
reality because no one disputes it,
right?
I mean,
even if you say that you don't believe
in pain,
it doesn't help when you're in pain,
you still believe in it,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's.
You can't pry it up with logic and
rationality,
it just stands forthe as as what the
fundament of existence and that's
actually quite useful to know.
Say,
well,
you don't want any more of that than is
absolutely necessary and I think that's
self evident and then you say,
wait a minute.
It's more complicated than that.
You don't want any more of that.
That's necessary today,
but also not tomorrow and not next week,
not next month,
not next year,
so however you act now better not
compromise how you're going to be in a
year because that would just be
counterproductive.
Now it's part of the problem with short
term pleasures,
right?
It's like active haste,
repented leisure.
Everyone knows exactly what that means,
so you have to act in a way that works
now and tomorrow and next week and next
month and so forth,
and so you have to take your future self
into account and human beings can do
that and taking your future self into
account isn't much different than taking
other people into account.
Right?
Because I remember there's this Simpson
episode and a homer downs,
a quart of Manet's and vodka.
He says,
someone's marge says,
you know,
you shouldn't really do that,
and homer says that's a problem for
future homer.
I share.
I'm sure glad I'm not.
That guy had so ridiculous.
They called Rico,
you know,
but but okay,
but you see we have to grapple with that
and so the you that's out there in the
future is sort of like another person.
And so figuring out how to conduct
yourself properly in relationship to
your future self isn't much different
than figuring out how to conduct
yourself in relationship to other
people,
but then we could expand the
constraints.
Not only does the interpretation that
you extract have to protect you from
suffering and give you an Ame,
but it has to do it in a way that's
iterable.
So it works across time and then it has
to work in the presence of other people
so that you can cooperate with them and
compete with them in a way that doesn't
make you suffer more.
And people are there.
They're not that tolerant.
You know what I mean?
They have choices.
They don't have to hang around with you.
They can hang around with any one of
these other primates,
and so if you don't act properly,
at least within certain boundaries,
it's like you're just cast aside and so
people are broadcasting information at
you all the time about how you need to
interpret the world so they can tolerate
being around you and you need that
because socially isolated,
you're insane and then your dad,
no one can tolerate being alone for any
length of time.
We can't maintain our own sanity without
continual feedback from other people
because it's too damn complicated.
So you're constrained by your own
existence and then you're constrained by
the existence of other people and then
you're also constrained by the world.
You know,
if I read hamlet and what I extract out
of that is the idea that I should jump
off a bridge.
It's like it's.
It puts my interpretation to an end
retailer rather quickly.
It doesn't seem to be optimally
functional,
let's say,
and so an interpretation has is
constrained by the reality of the world.
It's constrained by the reality of other
people and is constrained by your
reality across time and there's only a
small number of interpretations that are
going to work in that tightly defined
space,
and so that's part of the reason that
the postmodernists are wrong.
It's also part of the reason by the way
that ai people who've been trying to
make intelligent machines had had to put
them in a body is it turns out that you
just can't make something intelligent in
some sense,
without it being embodied,
and it's partly for the reasons that I
just described as you need constraints
on the system before you need
constraints on the system so that the
system doesn't drown in an infinite sea
of interpretation.
It's something like that.
So that's the literary end of it.
Moral while morality for me is about
action and I'm an existentialist in some
sense,
and what that means is that I believe
that what people believe to be true is
what they act out,
not what they say,
and so there's lots of definitions of
truth.
I mean,
truth is a very expansive word and you
can think of objective truth,
but behavioral truth isn't the same as
objective truth.
What you should do isn't the same as
what is as far as I can tell,
people debate that,
but I think the reason that that has to
be the case is because think about it
this way.
You're standing in front of a field and
you can see the field,
but the field doesn't tell you how to
walk through it.
There's an infinite number of ways you
could walk through it and so you can
extract out an inviolable guide to how
you should act from the array of facts
that are in front of you because there's
just too many facts and they don't have
directionality and but you,
you need to know.
You need to know how not to suffer and
you need to know what your aim is,
and so you have to overlay that
objective reality with some interpretive
structure and it's the nature of that
interpretive structure that we're going
to be aiming at.
Heart.
I've given you hints about it already.
We've extracted it in part from
observations of our own behavior and
other people's behavior and we've
extracted in part by the nature of our
embodiment that's been shaped over
hundreds of millions of years,
but we see the infinite plane of facts
and we impose a moral interpretation on
it and the moral interpretation is what
to do about what is and that's
associated both with security because
you just don't need too much complexity
and also with aim and so we're mobile
creatures,
right?
We need to know where we're going
because all were ever concerned about
roughly speaking is where we're going.
That's what we need to know.
Where are we going,
what are we doing,
and why?
And that's not the same question as what
is the world made of objectively,
it's a different question,
requires different answers,
and so that's the domain of the moral as
far as I'm concerned,
which is what are you aiming at?
What?
And that's the question of the ultimate
ideal in some sense.
Even if you have trivial little
fragmentary ideals,
there's there's something trying to
emerge out of that that's it's more
coherent and more integrated and more
applicable and more practical.
And that's the other thing is that you
know,
you think about literature and you think
about art and you think those aren't
very tightly tied to the earth.
They're imperial in area and spiritual
and they don't seem practical,
but I'm a practical person and part of
the reason that I wanted to assess these
books from a literary and aesthetic and
evolutionary perspective is to extract
out something of value.
Something of real value that's
practical.
You know,
something because one of the rules that
I have when I'm lecturing is that I
don't want to tell anybody anything that
they can't use because I think of
knowledge as a tool.
It states something to implement in the
world where tool,
using creatures and our knowledges,
tools and we need tools to work in the
world.
We need tools to regulate our emotions
and to make things better and to put an
end to suffering to the degree that we
can and to live with ourselves properly
and to stand up properly and you need
the tools to do that.
And so I don't want to do anything in
this lecture series that isn't
practical.
No.
I want you to come away having things
put together in a way that you can
immediately apply,
not interested in abstraction for the
sake of abstraction.
Rational.
Well,
it's gotTa make sense?
You know,
because the more restrictions on your
theory the better.
And so
I want it all laid out causally so that
a and a fall or be follows a and b
proceeds and in a way that's
understandable and doesn't require a
leap.
Any unnecessary leap of faith,
you know,
because that's another thing that I
think interferes with our relationship
with a collection of books like the
Bible is that you're called upon to
believe things that no one can believe.
And that's no good because that's a form
of lie as far as I can tell.
And then,
well then you have to scrap the whole
thing because in principle the whole
thing is about truth and if you have to
start your pursuit of truth by
swallowing a bunch of lies,
then how in the world are you going to
get anywhere with that?
And so I don't want any uncertainty at
the bottom of this.
Her,
I don't want any more than that.
I have to leave in it because I can't
get any farther than that.
And so we,
it's gonna make sense?
Rationally I want it.
I don't want it to be pushing up against
what we know to be scientifically
untrue,
even though science is in flux and
that's,
you know,
somewhat of a dangerous parameter I
don't want.
If it isn't working with evolutionary
theory,
for example,
then I think that it's not a good enough
solution.
So.
And then finally it's phenomenal.
Logical,
modern people.
No,
we think of the,
of reality as objective and that's very
powerful.
But that isn't how we experience
reality.
We have our domain of experience,
you know,
and it's a hard thing to get a grip on
even though it should be the most
obvious thing for the phenomenologists.
Everything that you experienced is real
and so they're interested in the
structure of your subjective experience.
I can say,
well,
you have subjective experience and you
have subjective experiences,
so to you,
and there's commonalities across all of
those.
Like for example,
you're.
You're likely to experience the same set
of emotions.
You know,
we've been able to identify canonical
emotions and canonical motivations,
and without that we couldn't even
communicate because you wouldn't know
what the other person was like.
You'd have to explain infinitely.
There's nothing you can take for
granted,
but you can.
You know when phenomenology is the fact
that in the center of my vision,
my hands are very clear and then out in
the periphery they get they disappear.
And phenomenology is the way things
smell and the way things taste and the
fact that they matter.
And so you could say in some sense that
phenomenology is the study of what
matters rather than matter.
And it's a given from the phenomenal
logical perspective that things have
meaning and that did any,
you know,
even if you're a rationalist saying
cynic and denialist and you say,
well,
nothing has any meaning.
You still run into the problem of pain
because pain undercuts your arguments
and has a meaning.
So there's no escaping from the meaning.
You can pretty much demolished all the
positive parts of it,
but trying to think your way out of the
negative parts.
Man,
good luck with that because that just
doesn't work.
So phenomenology is now the Bible
stories,
and I think this is true.
A fiction in general is phenomenal
logical and
it concentrates on trying to elucidate
the nature of human experience and that
is not the as the objective world,
but it's also a form of truth because it
is true that you have a field of
experience and that it has qualities.
The question is what are the qualities?
Now?
Ancient representations of reality.
We're sort of a weird meld of observable
phenomena.
Things that we would consider objective
facts and subjective truth,
the projection of subjective truth.
And I'll show you,
for example,
I'll show you how the Mesopotamians
viewed the world and they had a.
They had a model.
Basically the world was a disc.
You know,
if you go out into field at night,
what does the world look like?
Well,
it's a disc.
It's got a dome on top of it.
Well,
that was basically the Mesopotamian view
of the world view of the world that the
people who wrote the first stories in
the Bible believe too,
and an eye on top of the dome.
There was water.
While obviously it's like a range,
right?
Where does the water come from?
Well,
there's water around the dome and then
there's land that's the disk.
And then underneath that there's water.
How do you know that?
Well drill.
You'll hit water.
Well,
it's under the earth obviously,
because otherwise how would you hit the
water and then what's under that?
This freshwater.
And then what's under that?
Well,
if you go to the edge of the disc,
he hit the ocean.
It's sold water.
So it's a dome with water outside of it.
And then it's a desk that the dome sits
on.
And then underneath that there's fresh
water,
and then underneath that there's sold
water and that was roughly the
Mesopotamian world.
And you see,
you see that's a mix of observation and
imagination,
right?
Because that isn't the world,
but it is the way the world appears.
It's a perfectly believable cosmology
from and the sunrises and sunsets on
that dome.
It's not like the thing is bloody well
spinning.
Who would ever think that out?
It's obviously the sun comes up,
it goes down and then travels underneath
the world and comes back up again.
There's nothing more self evident than
that.
Well that's,
that's that strange intermingling of
subjective fantasy,
let's say right at the level of
perception and actual observable
phenomena.
And a lot of the cosmology that's
associated with the biblical stories is
exactly like that.
It's half psychology in half and half
and half reality.
Although the psychological is real as
well.
So,
so that an end to know that the biblical
stories have a phenomenal logical truth
is really worth knowing.
Because you know,
the poor fundamentalists,
they're trying to claim to their moral
structure and you know,
I understand why because it does
organize their societies and organizes
their psyche so they've got something to
cling to,
but you know,
they don't have a very sophisticated
idea of the complexity of what
constitutes truth and they try to
Gerrymander the biblical stories into
the domain of scientific theory.
You know,
creating,
promoting creationism,
for example,
has an alternative scientific theory.
It's like this,
just that just isn't gonna go anywhere,
you know,
because the people who wrote these damn
stories weren't scientists to begin
with.
There weren't any scientists back then.
There's hardly any scientists now.
You know,
it's,
it's really,
it's hard to think scientifically,
man.
It's like,
it takes a lot of training and even
scientists don't think scientifically
once you get the boat of the lab and
hardly even when they're in the lab,
you know,
you've got to get peer reviewed and
criticized and it gets hard to think
scientifically.
So in however,
the people who wrote these stories
thought it was more like dramatists,
think more like Shakespeare thought,
but that doesn't mean that there isn't
truth in it,
it just means that you have to be a
little bit more sophisticated about your
ideas of truth and that's okay.
You know,
there are truth to live by,
okay,
well fine.
Then we want to figure out what those
are because we need to live then maybe
not to suffer so much.
So,
so,
and so.
If you know that what the Bible stories
and stories in general are trying to
represent is the lived experience of
conscious individuals,
like the structure of the lived
experience of conscious individuals,
then that opens up the possibility of a
whole different realm of understanding,
eliminates the contradiction that's been
painful for people between the objective
world and,
and let's say the claims of religious
stories.
So,
okay,
okay.
So let's,
let's,
let's take a look at the structure of
the book itself.
So the first thing about the Bible is
that it's a comedy and a comedy has a
happy ending,
right?
So that's a strange thing because the
Greek God stories were almost always
tragic.
Now the Bible is a comedy.
It has a happy ending.
Everyone lives.
There's a habit.
So now what you think about that as a
completely different issue.
I'm just telling you the structure of
the story.
It's something like there was paradise
at the beginning of time and then some
cataclysmic occurred and people fell
into history and history is limitation
and mortality and suffering and self
consciousness,
but there's a mode of being or
potentially the establishment of the
state that will transcend that and
that's what time is aiming at.
So that's the.
That's the idea of the story.
You know,
it's a funny thing that the Bible has
this story because it wasn't written as
a book,
right?
It was assembled from a whole bunch of
different books and the fact that it got
assembled into something resembling a
story is quite remarkable.
And what the question is then,
well,
what is that story about and,
and how did it come up as a story?
And then I suppose as well,
is there anything to it?
It constitutes a dramatic record of self
realization or obstruction already
mentioned.
That is like the idea,
for example,
of the formulation of the,
let's say the image of God is an
abstraction.
That's how we're gonna handle it.
To begin with.
I want to say though,
because I said I wasn't going to be any
more reductionist than necessary.
I know that the evidence for genuine
religious experience is
incontrovertible,
but it's not explicable and so I don't
want to explain it away.
I want to just leave it as a fact and
then I want to pull back from that and
say,
okay,
well we'll leave that as a fact and the
mystery and what we'll look at this.
We're going to look at this from a
rational perspective and say that the
initial formulation of the idea of God
was an attempt to abstract out the ideal
and to do consider it as a abstraction
outside its instantiation,
so and that's good enough.
That's amazing.
That's an amazing thing.
If it's true,
but I don't want to
throw out the baby with the bath water.
Let's say it's a collection of books
with multiple redactors and editors.
So what does that mean?
Many people wrote it.
There's many different books even and
they're interwoven together,
especially in the first five books by
people who I suspect took the traditions
of tribes that had been brought together
under a single political organization
and tried to make their accounts
coherent and so it took a little of this
and they took a little of that and they
took a little of this and they and they
tried not to lose anything because it
seemed valuable or it was certainly
valuable to the people who had collected
the stories.
They weren't gonna,
you know,
tolerate too much editing,
but they also wanted it to make sense to
some degree.
So it wasn't completely logically
contradictory and,
and,
and completely absurd and so many people
wrote it and many people edited and many
people assembled it over a vast stretch
of time.
And we have very few documents like
that.
And so just because we have a document
like that is sufficient reason to to
look at it as a remarkable phenomena and
try to understand what it is that it's
trying to communicate,
let's say.
And then I said it's also the world's
first hyperlink text,
which is,
which is that again,
very much we're thinking about for quite
a long time.
All right.
There's four sources
in the old testament or the Hebrew Bible
for stories that we know came together.
One was called the priestly.
There's a source called the priestly,
and he used the name below him or El
Shaddai for God and I believe Al is the
root word for Ela as well,
so and that's usually translated as God
or gods because below him is is utilized
as plural in the beginning books of the
Bible and it's newer than a yard was
version.
Now the reason I'm telling you that is
because genesis one,
which is the first story,
isn't as old as genesis two.
Genesis contains the yard,
was fruit,
contains the story,
for example,
of Adam and eve,
and that's older than the very first
book in the Bible,
but they decided to put a newer version
first and what isn't,
and I think it's because it deals with
more fundamental abstractions.
It's something like that.
It's like it deals with the most basic
of abstractions,
how the universe was created and then
segues into what the human is like.
And so that seems to be the logic behind
it.
The yard was version uses the name,
why h,
two h,
which apparently people didn't say,
but we believe was pronounced,
something like Yahuah,
um,
and it,
it has a strongly anthropomorphic God.
So one that takes human form.
It begins with genesis two,
four.
This is the account of the heavens and
the earth.
Wind and contains the story of Adam and
Eve and Cain and Abel and Noah and the
Tower of Babel in exodus and numbers
alone with priestly version.
It also contains the law in the form,
just the form of the 10 commandments,
which is like a truncated form of the,
of the law.
There's
the
Elo has a source,
it contains the stories of Abraham and
Isaac it.
It's concerned with a heavenly hierarchy
that includes angels.
It talks about the departure from Egypt,
and it presents the Covenant Code,
which is this idea of,
you know,
that society is predicated.
This was Israeli society.
It was predicated on a covenant with God
and that's laid out in a sequence of
rules,
some of which are the 10 commandments,
but many of which are much more
extensive than that.
And then the final one is the
deuteronomistic code and it contains the
bulk of the law and the what's called
the Deuterenomic history and it's
independent of Genesis,
exodus,
leviticus,
and numbers.
And so we know that at least for now
there's debate about this.
Like there is about everything you know,
so I'm brushing over a very large area
of scholarship,
but people generally assume that there
were multiple authors over multiple
periods of time.
And the way they've concluded that is by
looking at textual analysis.
You know,
trying to see where there are chunks of
the stories that have the same kind of
style or the same reference.
People argue about that because you
know,
obviously it's difficult to recreate
something ancient,
but that's,
that's the basic idea.
So it is an amalgam of viewpoints about
these initial issues and,
and that's important to know.
So it's like a collective.
It's a collective story and uh,
okay.
Now to understand the first part of
Genesis,
I'm going to turn strangely enough to
something that's actually part of the
New Testament and this is a central
element of Christianity and it's a very
strange idea and it's going to take a
very long time to unpack,
but the idea,
this is what John said about Christ,
he said in the beginning was the word.
And so that relates back to genesis one.
In the beginning was the word and the
word was with God and the word was gone.
Have some.
Well,
you know,
three sentences like that take a lot of
unpacking because,
well,
none of that seems to make any sense
whatsoever.
Really.
Right.
In the beginning was the word and the
word was with God and the word was God.
So the first question might be what in
the does that mean in the beginning was
the word that's the logos actually on
the logos is embodied in the figure of
Christ.
So there's this idea in John,
whatever Christ is,
the son of God is not only instantiated
in history,
say at a particular time and place as a,
as a carpenter in some backwoods part of
the world,
but also something eternal that exists
outside of time and space that was there
right at the beginning and as far as I
can tell what that logo represents.
It's something like modern people.
It's something like what modern people
refer to when they talk about
consciousness.
It's something like that.
It's more than that.
It's like consciousness and its capacity
to to be aware and its capacity to
communicate if something like that.
And there's an ID underneath that which
is that being especially from a
phenomenal logical perspective.
So the being that is experienced cannot
exist without consciousness.
It's like consciousness shines a light
on things to bring it into being because
without consciousness,
what is there no one experiences.
Anything is like is there a.
is there anything when no one
experiences anything?
That's the question and the answer that
this book is presenting is that no,
you have to think about consciousness as
a constituent element of reality.
It's something that's necessary for
reality.
It extends itself to exist.
Now of course it depends on what you
mean by reality,
but the reality that's being referred to
here,
I told you already is this strange
amalgam of the subjective experience and
the world,
but the question is deeper than that too
because it is by no means obvious what
there is.
If there's no one to experience it.
I mean the whole notion of time itself
seems to collapse at least in terms of
something like felt duration and then
the notion of size disappears
essentially because there's nothing to
scale it and the causality seems to
vanish and so and and we don't
understand consciousness.
Not In the least.
We don't understand what it is that is
in us.
That gives illumination to be.
And what happens in the Old Testament,
at least in part,
is that that consciousness is associated
with the divine.
Now you think,
well,
is that a reasonable proposition and
that's a very complicated question,
but at least we might know that there's
something to the claim because there is
a miracle of experience and existence
that's dependent on consciousness.
I mean people try to explain it away
constantly,
but it doesn't seem to work very well
and here's something else to think
about.
I think it's really worth thinking
People do not like it when you treat
them like they're not conscious,
right?
They react very badly to that and then
you don't like it.
If someone assumes that you're not
conscious and you don't like it,
if someone assumes that you don't have
freewill,
you know that you're just absolutely
determined in your,
in your actions and there's nothing
that's going to repair you and that you
don't need to have any responsibility
for your actions.
It's like our culture,
the laws of our culture are predicated
on the idea.
Something like people are conscious,
people have experienced people make
decisions and can be held responsible
for them.
That there's a freewill element to it
and you can debate all that
philosophically and fine,
but the point is is that that is how we
act and that is the idea that our legal
system is predicated on and there's
something deep about it because you know
you're subject to the law,
but the law is also limited by you,
which is to say that in a well
functioning,
properly grounded democratic system,
you have intrinsic value.
That's the source of your rights.
Even if you're a murderer,
we have to say the law can only go so
far because there's something about you
that's divine.
Well.
What does that mean?
Well,
partly it means that there's something
about you that's conscious and capable
of communicating like your whole world
and unto yourself and you have that to
contribute to everyone else,
and that's valuable mean that you can
learn new things.
You can transform the structure of
society.
You can invent a new way of dealing with
the world.
You're capable of old,
that it's an intrinsic part of you and
that's associated with this.
It's associated.
That's the idea there is that there's
something about the logos that is
necessary for the absolute chaos of the
reality beyond experience to manifest
itself as reality.
It's an amazing idea because it gives
consciousness a constitute of role in
the cosmos and you can debate that,
but you know it's not.
You can't just bloody well brush it off
because first of all,
we are the most complicated things there
are that we know of by,
by a massive,
by,
by a massive amount were so complicated
that it's unbelievable.
And so,
you know,
there's a lot of cosmos out there,
but there's a lot of cosmos in here too.
And which one is greater is by no means
obvious unless you use something trivial
like relative size,
which you know really isn't a very
sophisticated approach and whatever it
is that is you has this capacity to
experience reality and to transform it,
which is very strange thing.
You know,
you can conceptualize a future in your
imagination and then you can work and
make that manifest.
You participate in the process of
creation.
That's one way of thinking about it.
And so that's why I think in genesis
one,
it re,
it relates to the idea that human beings
are made in the image of the divine men
and women,
which is interesting too,
because you know,
the feminists are always criticizing
Christianity,
for example,
as being what inexorably patriarchal or
as they criticize everything like that.
So it's,
it's hardly a stroke,
a bloody brilliance.
But I think it's an absolute miracle
that right at the beginning of the
document it says straightforwardly like
with no hesitation whatsoever,
the divine spark which were associated
with the word that brings forth being is
manifest in men and women equally.
It's a very cool thing.
And you gotta think,
well,
like I said,
they actually take that seriously.
Well,
what you got to ask is what happens if
you don't take it seriously,
right?
That's reading,
read Dostoyevsky's crime and punishment.
That's the best,
the best investigation of that tactic
that's ever been produced.
Because what happens in Dostoyevsky's
crime and punishment is that the main
character whose name is [inaudible]
cough decides that there's no intrinsic
value to other people and that as a
consequence,
he can do whatever he wants.
It's only cowardice that stops him from
acting,
right?
Because why would it be anything else if
other people,
if the value of other people is just an
arbitrary superstition,
then why can't I do exactly what I want
when I want,
which is the psychopaths viewpoint.
Well,
so regarding the cough does he killed
someone who's a very horrible person and
he has very good reasons for killing her
and he's half starved and a little bit
insane and possessed by this ideology.
It's brilliant,
brilliant layout and he finds out
something after he kills her,
which is that the post killing Roscoe
and the carbon,
the pre killing risk walnut cove are not
the same person even a little bit
because he's broken a rule like he's
broken and serious rule and there's no
going back and crime and punishment is
is,
is a,
is the best investigation I know of of
what happens.
If you take the notion that there's
nothing defined about the individual,
seriously now you.
No.
Most of the people I know who are deeply
atheistic and I understand why they're
deeply atheistic,
they haven't contended with people like
Dostoevsky,
not as far as I can tell because I don't
see logical flaws in crime and
punishment.
I think he got the psychology exactly
right and he Dostoyevsky's amazing for
this because in one of his books,
the devil's,
for example,
he describes a political scene scenario
that's not much different than the one
we find yourself in now and there are
these people who are possessed by
rationalistic utopian atheistic ideas
and they're very powerful.
They give rise to the communist
revolution,
right?
I mean,
they're powerful ideas and his character
Stavenhagen also acts out the the,
the presupposition that human beings
have no intrinsic nature and no
intrinsic value and it's Britain,
other brilliant investigation and
Dostoevsky prophesies.
That's what I would say.
What will happen to a society if it goes
down that road and he was dead.
Exactly accurate.
It's uncanny to read Dostoyevsky's,
the Pisaster,
the devil's depending on the translation
and then to read Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn
Gulag archipelago because one is fiction
and prophecy and the second is,
hey look,
it turned out exactly the way the
Dostoyevsky said it would for exactly
the same reasons.
So it's quite remarkable.
So well.
So the question is do you seriously with
the idea that a,
there's something can't cosmically
constitutive about consciousness and be
that,
that might well be considered divine and
see that that is instantiated in every
person and then ask yourself if you're
not a criminal,
if you don't act it out and then ask
yourself what that means.
Is that reflective of a reality or is it
a metaphor like maybe it's a metaphor,
complex metaphor that we have to use to
organize her societies could well be,
but even as a metaphor,
it's,
it's true enough so that we mess with it
at our peril and it also took people a
very long time to figure out.
This is genesis one.
You know what?
I'm probably going to stop there because
I believe it's 9:30
and so we didn't even get to the first
line.
Yeah,
yeah.
I want to read you a couple of things
that we'll use as a pro drama for the
next lecture because our.
I'll just bounce through a collection of
ideas that's associated with the notion
of divinity.
Okay.
And then we'll turn back to the first
lines when we start the next one.
I have no idea how far I'm going to get
through the biblical stories by the way,
because I'm trying to figure this out as
I go along.
Okay.
So you know there's an idea in
Christianity that God,
that the image of God is a trinity,
right?
There's the father is the father,
there's the element of the sun and
there's the element of the Holy Spirit
is something like tradition,
the spirit of tradition.
It's something like the human being as
the newest incarnation of that
tradition,
like the living incarnation of that
tradition and then then it's something
like the spirit in people that makes
relationship with this and this
possible,
the spirit and individuals,
and so I'm going to bounce my way
quickly through some of the classical
metaphorical attributes of God so that
we kind of have a cloud of notions about
what we're talking about when we
returned to genesis one and talk about
the God who spoke can you into to be so
there's a fatherly aspect.
So here's what God as a father is like.
You can enter into a covenant with it so
you can make a bargain with it.
Now you think about that.
Money is like that because money is a
bargain you make with the future.
Right?
And so we structured our world so that
you can negotiate with the future and I
don't think that we would have gone to
the point where we could do that without
having this idea to begin with.
You can.
You can act as if the future is a
reality.
There's a spirit of tradition that
enables you to act as if the future is
something that can be bargained with.
That's why you make sacrifices.
Right,
and the sacrifices were acted out for a
very long period of time and now they're
psychological.
We know that you can sacrifice something
valuable in the present and expect that
you're negotiating with something that
represents the transcendent future,
and that's a map.
Amazing human discovery like no other
creature can do that,
to act as if the future is real,
to know that you can bargain with
reality itself and that you can do it
successfully.
It's an unbelievable.
It responds to sacrifice.
It answers prayers.
I'm not saying that any of this is true
by the way.
I'm just saying what the what the cloud
of ideas represents.
It punishes and rewards it judges and
forgives.
It's not nature.
You see the thing about the thing that's
one of the thing that's weird about the
Judeo Christian tradition is that God
and nature are not the same thing at
all.
Whatever God is partially manifest in
this logo,
something that stands outside of nature,
and that's.
I think that's something like
consciousness as abstracted from the
natural world,
so it built even for mankind and then
banished us for disobedience.
It's too powerful to be touched.
It granted freewill distance from it is
hell distance from it,
his death.
It reveals itself in Dogma and had
mystical experience and it's the law,
so that's sorta like the fatherly aspect
and then the sun like aspect.
It speaks chaos into order.
It slays dragons and feeds people with
the remains.
It finds gold,
rescues virgins.
It's the body and blood of Christ.
It's a tragic victim and scapegoat and
eternally Triano Triumphant Redeemer
simultaneously.
It cares for the outcast.
It dies and is reborn.
It's the king of kings and hero of
heroes.
It's not the state,
but it's both.
It's both the fulfillment and critic of
this state.
It dwells in the perfect house.
It is aiming at Paradise or heaven.
It can rescue from hell.
It cares for the outcast.
It's the foundation stone and the
cornerstone that was rejected and it's
the spirit of the law
and then its spirit like it's akin to
the human soul.
It's the prophetic voice.
It's the still small voice of
conscience.
It's the spoken truth.
It's called forth by music.
It is the enemy of deceit,
arrogance,
and resentment.
It's the water of life.
It burns without consuming,
and it's a blinding light.
Okay,
so that's a very,
that's a very well developed poetic set
of poetic metaphors essentially.
Right?
So these are all,
what would you say?
Glimpses of the,
of the transcendent ideal.
That's the right way of thinking about
their glimpses of the transcendent ideal
and all of them have a specific meaning
and well in part that we're going to do
is go over that meaning as we continue
with this,
with this series.
And so what we've got now is a brief
description at least of what this is.
In the beginning,
God created the heavens and the earth.
We know it's with the logos
in this sequence of stories.
We know it's associated with the word
end with consciousness and we know that
it's associated with whatever God is and
then I laid out the metaphoric landscape
that at least in part describes God and
so now we have some sense of the being
that does this creates the heavens and
the earth.
The earth was without form and void.
That's that chaotic state of
intermingled confusion and darkness was
over the face of the deep and the spirit
of God was hovering over the face of the
waters and God said,
let there be light and there was light
and so we'll stop with that because now
we're ready to take attendance of step
into the very first part of this book
and it's important to have your
conceptual framework properly organized
so that you can appreciate where it's
going and what it might possibly meet.
And so well,
I've done what I can today to.
What would you say,
elaborate on this single word I suppose
and,
but it's a big word,
you know,
so it's not so unreasonable that it
takes a long time to get to the point
where you have any sense of what it
means at all.
All right.
That is nowhere near.
That is not.
I thought I would get a lot farther.
Alright.
So thank you.
Thank you.
So we do have time for some questions.
We have to be out of here at 10:30.
It's 9:30.
So maybe we'll have questions until
someone crazy grubs,
microphone or maybe we'll have questions
for half an hour,
something like that.
And so if anybody has any questions then
there's a microphone there and there's a
microphone there and I'll try to answer
them to the best that I can miss the my
ability.
So let's.
Sure,
let's start.
Okay.
So you talked about the idea of when
you're confronting something that you
fear you,
like you face it head on and you destroy
it,
but then you said that the idea is when
you're confronting something you make
the world that have it.
And I was wondering if you could just,
I mean,
just expound on,
that means you make your marriage out of
the arguments.
You know,
when you have arguments with your wife,
you have arguments with your children,
that's that chaotic state because no
one's been able to formulate a habitable
order from that,
that domain of controversy and
confusion.
And then through dialogue you erect a
structure that's a house that you can
both live in.
And so that's the.
That's the idea of making the world out
of that chaos.
And it's frightening because you know,
if you're really ha,
this is why people often avoid having
disputes with people they love because
it's frightening,
right?
You find out what the person's light and
you find out what your life is like,
God,
who wants to do that?
Nobody.
So you know,
your heart rate goes up and it's it.
It's confrontation and conflict and,
and,
and that's because you're encountering
that domain that hasn't been properly
mapped,
are configured and so,
and you're doing that with your Predator
detection systems essentially.
And so that chaos that it threatens the
stability of the marriage is equivalent
to,
while it's equivalent to the serpent and
the tree,
that's one form of equivalence.
And,
and then by dialogue,
through dialogue and negotiation,
you formulate the problem,
what exactly is going on here,
where exactly are we,
what exactly is the problem?
And so you keep talking until you reach
a consensus about that,
when you can live with,
when you can act out right.
And then you and maybe you come up with
a solution to the problem and you've
established piece again and peace.
That's the house that you can both live
in.
And that's the chaos.
That's the chaos that people can fall
into all the time and often do.
And it's the chaos that makes a marriage
wash up on the shores and transform into
like,
you know,
15 year divorce court,
very horrible thing.
So that's the idea.
Okay.
Thank you.
Hi Dr Allison.
Thank you so much for the talk and
thanks for your teachings.
It's really helped me a lot.
I had a experience in Grad school,
two English degrees and the way he
described the humanities in my
experience,
help me understand my experience back
then.
So thank you.
So it's too bad.
That's too bad that,
that happens to be the case.
I really like that.
You know,
it's,
it's really not good,
but you don't have to tell me that,
but,
you know,
I survived and I learned a lot and,
I'm not,
you know,
ungrateful for my experience.
I've learned a lot.
Um,
but you said something,
you described the Bible,
the collection of stories in the Bible
and interesting way,
and I wonder if it was on purpose,
uh,
you described it as,
um,
created by an assembly of stories
created by many people over time.
Uh,
that's hyperlinked into itself.
And it sounds a lot like how I have
description of like the internet and
like how that works.
Yeah,
well it's not,
it's not accidental.
I mean,
because the Internet's also a
collective.
It's a collective endeavor.
God only knows what personality it's
going to manifest,
you know,
but it's going to manifest some
personality because it's learning to
understand us very,
very rapidly.
So I think you could,
there's no reason not to think about it
as a precursor.
I mean the distance between the Bible
and the Internet is a lot less than the
distance between a chimpanzee and a
human being.
So it's a.
and the difference between a book and
the Internet is,
it's also,
it's in some sense it's a matter of new
matter of degree rather than kind.
So,
so in a personality,
personality gets in by separating,
it sounds like you're talking about.
I know I can't speculate,
you know,
because God only knows what's going to
happen in the next 20 years.
I certainly don't.
And so I don't know what the
preconditions are for consciousness.
I have no idea and I don't think anybody
knows.
So I guess we're gonna find out.
Yup.
Yup,
Hey Dr Peterson,
I'm curious about the connection between
aesthetic beauty and religious
experience.
I think you've hinted at it once or
twice over the course of this lecture.
Um,
is it possible for something that's
incredibly beautiful to evoke or
religion,
religious or mystical experience or
something and in the same ballpark,
that's what they're for.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
If you look at the structure of like a,
like a Renaissance Cathedral just
yesterday was just going to check my,
uh,
my tag onto.
I apologize you mentioned trump might
tag onto that question.
The next part was,
um,
is that why we have cathedrals built
like a spectacular buildings as opposed
to a box or something?
Right?
Well,
it says if you're going to,
how's the ultimate ideal,
you build something beautiful right to,
to represent it's dwelling place and it
should be beautiful.
And this is something that people do.
You know,
what takes seriously,
and this is especially something we
don't take seriously in Canada.
I mean,
one of the,
you think about,
you think about all the hundreds of
millions of dollars that were invested
into beauty and in Europe mean
spectacular,
excessive investment in beauty that's
paid back.
God only knows how many multiples of
times people make pilgrimages to Europe
constantly because it's so beautiful
that it just staggers you.
Beauty is so valuable and when we're so
afraid of it,
and I think we're afraid of it because
it does.
It's a pathway.
It's not the only pathway to the divine.
I mean there's lot.
There's pathways to the divine.
Love is one of them,
I suppose,
but beauty especially for people who
have an affinity for beauty,
it's,
it's like music.
It's one of those things that you can't
argue against,
right?
You can't even understand.
It just hits you and it does.
It shows you.
Well,
it shows you the ideal.
That's one way of thinking about it,
but it also shows you,
I think it's like a vision of the
potential future.
It's something like that as well,
that if we just got her act together and
beautified things that that's the place
that we can inhabit and that would end
us and that's why this Jerusalem heavily
city is paved with gemstones.
You know,
their crystalline,
the admit light and yeah,
it's the proper dwelling place for an
enlightened God is the proper dwelling
place for an enlightened consciousness
and we ignore it at our spiritual and
economic peril.
It's like,
it's obvious that duty.
There's almost nothing more valuable
than beauty economically,
practically.
Right.
So yeah,
why that is.
I mean,
I don't.
It's very,
who knows.
I mean why we experienced gemstones for
example,
is beautiful.
It's very mysterious,
but they're deep reasons for it.
So.
Yeah.
Alright,
I have a bit of a similar question
actually.
I know one of the ways in which,
um,
the Bible is appreciated even by some of
its harshest critics and deeply a people
is as a work of literature and is
something I'm at least I'm the King
James or the authorized translation of
the Bible is something very
aesthetically beautiful and a great work
of literature and a great work of
poetry.
Um,
and I'm wondering just from your study
of it and from your personal
perspective,
if there's any,
any particular passages or are parts of
it that you find particularly have
struck you in that way or that you,
that you cherish more than,
more than any others that you'd be able
to share or.
Well,
the ones that have really opened,
the ones that have really opened up to
me I think are the stories in genesis
right up to the tower of Babel because I
think,
well hopefully I'll be able to talk to
all of you about that,
but I think I got some sense of what
they mean and why.
I mean I know it's not exhaustive and
obviously but like and then the story in
exodus as well.
I also feel like I've got a handle on
that and so those have those have hit me
really,
really hard and that,
you know what I mean?
Just trying to understand this first
part of genesis to try to understand
what these concepts mean has been.
Especially when I started to understand
that the concept that human beings are
made in God's image,
God is has all those attributes that we
just described,
that human beings are made in God's
image,
but that's actually the cornerstone of
our legal system.
That really,
that really rattled me because I didn't
understand that clearly that our body of
laws has that metaphysical
presupposition without which the laws
fall apart and that's starting to
happen.
It really is.
You know,
like the postmodern critique of law.
The law schools are,
I would say they're overrun by
postmodernists two are undermining the
structure of western law as fast as they
possibly can because they don't buy any
of this and so they're much more likely
to just think of the law is something at
like a like a casual pragmatic tool to
be manipulated for the purposes of
bringing forth the utopia.
It's a really,
really,
really bad idea.
So it's very strange to me that we go
off track when that metaphysical
foundation starts to get rattled.
So
do you think your,
your appreciation of the aesthetic
beauty of it comes from a belief in the
truth that it's the underlying
propositions.
I mean that's just because even the
atheistic critics,
I'm thinking of like even Dawkins or
hitchens really appreciate the Bible as
just a piece of I'm really beautiful
literature and I guess the quality of
the writing and the sort of exalted
themes behind it,
even if they totally reject the
underlying premises of it,
but you seem to.
Yeah,
well I don't,
I don't think that you can see it as
beautiful and poetic with the and reject
the underlying premises because if you
see it as beautiful and poetic,
you're accepting the underlying premises
with your experience of the beauty and
the poetics,
even though you may be fighting it with
your articulated rationality.
So I think all that indicates is a
disintegrated perspective on the book.
Not.
It's not surprising that that's the
case.
I mean it,
it,
it's the perspective that everyone has
on the book except with them.
It's more well developed and well
thought through,
but I think it's fundamentally they're
not approaching the thing with enough
respect.
That's my sense is they and who knows,
right.
Because I don't.
I don't know,
but what I've tried to do is to think
there's probably more to this than I
know,
and then try to understand it from that
perspective rather than to think,
for example,
once a collection of of superstitions
that we've somehow grown.
It's like,
no,
it's just.
Sorry that's,
that's not a deep enough analysis
because it's got some truth,
but it doesn't take into account the
fact that the proposition still stand at
the foundation of our culture.
It doesn't address niches,
central concern,
which is that if you blow out the notion
of God,
the entire structure crumbled and Owen,
you can debate that fine.
But I just,
you know,
just assume that you debated it with
nature because he's a pretty tough
customer to tangle with.
So I don't think the,
the atheist types in so far as there's a
type.
I don't think they've wrestled with the
real problems.
So.
Yeah.
So I appreciate you setting some ground
rules.
Keep things rational and,
uh,
I think that's going to help us.
What I'm wondering is,
so for instance,
you had said elsewhere,
the new testament from the best from
what you can see it's psychologically
correct.
Uh,
and that's quite astounding.
I would say there's a lot of truth and
in your depictions of these stories
elsewhere,
you've pointed out like deep truths,
you know,
the real powerful.
So what my question would be is if we
can say Nietzsche took a,
like in order of magnitude of a
intelligence and the depth to be able to
predict what would happen to the next
side century,
you know,
rationally if the Bible's not the
inherent word of God,
what's going on?
That's a good question.
That's a really good question.
I mean,
I'm going to try to answer that
rationally but uh,
but,
uh,
and as we move forward,
but as I said,
I don't want to leave people with the
notion because you know,
some ways.
This is something I've thought about.
What I've been thinking about for a long
time is I can't tell if I'm a like an
advocate of the religious viewpoint or
its worst possible critic because I am
doing my best to make it rational and
there's an reductionistic element to
that,
but I think that I'm doing that while
also leaving the door open to things
that I don't understand because I know
that there's.
There's more to this story than I
understand or can understand and I'm
laying out what I can understand it.
I'm making it rational,
but I do not believe for an instant that
that exhausts the realm.
It's like there.
There are ways of interpreting these
stories that work in the conceptual
universe we inhabit right now,
but there's a lot of things that we
don't understand.
What I'm thing I found about digging
into these stories is that the deeper
you dig,
the more you find,
and that's pretty damned.
That's one of the things that convinced
me that there was more to them that I
had originally suspected because things
would click and I think,
wow,
that's really.
That's really something and then I would
take it apart further and I think whole,
well I thought that was something,
but this is.
This is even more remarkable.
It just keeps opening and opening and so
I'm going to make it rational.
I'm going to try to provide an answer to
and it is.
I think you're right about speaking
about niche and his capacity for
prophecy and Dostoyevsky's in the same
category,
so like there are prophetic elements to
the old and New Testament that seemed to
stretch over much vaster spans of time
and I'm going to try to produce a
rational account of that.
But I mean one of the reasons that I
think the new testament is
psychologically true,
let's say is because,
and this is one of the things that's,
that's,
that's deeply embedded in the structure
of the Bible.
In the Old Testament.
There's this idea and I'm skipping
ahead,
that through a succession of states,
the people who behave properly will
eventually establish the proper state.
And so the state is viewed in some sense
as the,
as the entity of salvation.
But what happens in the new testament is
that idea gets,
you could say deconstructed and instead
of a state being the place of
redemption,
a state of being becomes the State of
redemption.
And so the idea that human beings will
be redeemed moves from the Utopian state
vision to the responsibility of the
individual.
And I think that's correct.
I mean,
I believe that that's the right answer.
And I think that West in particular is
predicated on the idea that idea because
it makes the state subservient to the
individual.
I mean there's a,
there's a what,
a dialogue,
a continual dialogue.
But in the final analysis,
the locus of the divine is the
individual,
not the state.
And I believe that that's so true,
that if we don't act it out and believe
it,
then all die painfully.
And that's true enough for me.
So thank you.
Yeah.
Or eliminating talk.
I'm going to keep you on the creation
story and if you don't mind,
because we know this editing that was
done,
there was the purpose for the editing.
Can you give us your thoughts about the
difference in the story of creation,
especially pertaining to men from the
first chapter,
which is very godlike,
you know,
by a word after the second one,
which is more like a fatherly type of
creation.
Is it a selling point?
What was the reason for this type of
editing to put the two together?
Well,
I think you know,
the more cynical would you call critic
criticisms of the Bible and the
religious tradition,
criticisms like Marxists or Freud's even
for that matter make the case that it's
a power.
It's a manifestation of power in
politics and that there's always a
political or economic motivation behind
the construction of the stories and I
think that that's true to some degree,
but I don't think that it's true enough
so that you can take that particular
interpretive tack and be done with it.
And I would say that to the degree that
there are political and economic
motivations that have shaped the
stories,
the fact that multiple stories have come
together,
they're sort of corrective in some
sense.
And so even at the level of detail,
there's political intrigue and politics
say with regards to the ascendancy of
Israel,
when you step away from it,
it becomes something that's more
universal and escapes from that.
And how that happened.
Oh,
I don't know.
I mean,
I think safe to say it's reasonably safe
to say that the people who put this
document together,
they did two things.
I think they were guided by their
aesthetic taste and their conscience.
I truly believe that.
And the reason I believe that is because
I think anything that was propagandistic
would have been forgotten because he
can't remember propaganda.
No one likes it.
It's like it's dead 10 years after you
write it or 20 years.
And it isn't only that these books were
assembled in written.
It was that they were preserved and
remembered.
And to me that means they have an
affinity with the structure of memory.
I mean,
you think about it,
how does this story last 10,000
years,
unless it's the kind of story you can
remember,
it doesn't because you forget all of
forgettable stuff and all you remember
is the memorable stuff.
And so there's this,
there's this interplay between the
document itself,
found its audience that shapes the
document.
And so now,
I don't know how specifically I answered
your question.
Um,
we're going to hit this different
stories as they come up and sequence and
I think I'll shed some more light on the
relationship between doing that and
we'll start with that next week.
Okay,
great.
So,
um,
I've been really interested in a lot of
the stuff that you've been saying about
dreams because I've been lucid dreaming
a lot for many years,
but always in a sort of atheistic way.
It's sort of like a game or something
like that.
But um,
because of seeing your talks and
everything,
I've started to think of it from a
different perspective.
Like you're now interfacing with
something beyond the narrow scope of
your conscious awareness that or
something like that,
maybe mythological or maybe something
like God.
And so what I've been thinking about and
what I maybe wonder what you think about
it is that in some ways when you're
lucid dreaming,
you're kind of tread.
You're getting beyond the limitations of
an ordinary dream or sort of trends
sending limitations,
which maybe is like,
it's not the purpose of people,
right?
It's because as a person who was
supposed to be limited in some way as
opposed to like God who's like not
limited and how,
but on the other hand it's a good
opportunity to kind of have control over
your interactions with this like very
special and interesting thing.
So I guess the conundrum is that on one
hand like you can,
you can control your interactions,
but on the other hand,
like you are controlling them.
So I guess I'm wondering what you think
about that and also just in general,
what do you think about lucid dreaming
as a thing?
Like should you do it?
Or.
I had a client who could really lucid
dream,
you know,
and one of the things she used them now
and then to solve problems even though
she didn't always pay attention to that
answer,
but sometimes she did.
She went to her in one of her dreams,
one of the characters told her that she
would have to learn to live in a
slaughter house.
She was very afraid of life and one of
the consequences of that was that we
went and watched an embalming,
so,
so the dreams were.
But one of the things she did,
she'd asked the characters what they
were up to,
you know,
she was instead of controlling,
she would inquire and so,
but I don't know what to say about lucid
dreaming beyond that.
Like I know it's a well documented
phenomenon and many people can do it and
women seem to be able to do it better
than men.
That's what the research indicates.
But I think that what we don't know
about lucid dreaming could fill a lot of
books.
So I think you do.
There is some danger in controlling it,
I think because you lose the spontaneous
revelation,
although not completely because he can't
control it completely,
but I like you see,
you might be interested in reading
humans works on active imagination
because he kind of learned to dream when
he was awake and he spent a lot of time
in the world of imagination when he was
awake.
The red books,
for example,
the red book is as a document of his
experiences with awake dreaming,
but he was very interactive with the
dream,
you know,
instead of trying to bend it to his
Morris will,
he was,
he was exploring it in some sense like
you explore a video game right now which
are forms of dreams in and of
themselves.
So yeah,
I would say do it with an exploratory
purpose in mind and you could always ask
yourself what you could learn to,
which is a very dangerous question to
ask a dream because sometimes you'll
find out what you have to learn.
Now it's not so pleasant,
but it's really worthwhile.
Okay.
Yup.
Okay,
so I think,
I think I'm going to take four more
questions only because I'm running out
of brain and I don't want to say stupid
things,
so or stupid or things that I've already
said so.
So yeah.
Thank you for the talk.
I'm in the beginning of your lecture,
you talked about how society needed this
kind of dreamlike religious base,
so we don't go between left and right
violently and we can kind of have this
base and then you also said you admired
Nisha for kind of a chopping down these,
these ideological and kind of dogmatic
weeds coming up from the base of
Christianity.
I was wondering how what your thoughts
are on how society can have this kind of
religious base without having these kind
of dangerous ideologies that can spring
up once a month.
That's what I'm trying to figure out.
Not really.
I mean that really that's the serious
answer to that question.
No,
I mean the reason that I'm an admirer of
niches because he was the spirit of his
time,
so that's a good way of thinking about
it.
It's not like nature killed God.
It's the nature gathered what was in the
air and articulated it right incredibly
profoundly in so he put his finger on
the spot and in doing so he announced
the problem and once you announced the
problem,
then maybe you can come up with a
solution because you can't solve a
problem unless you know what it is and
the fact that he made it so stark and so
clear,
it was horrifying in some sense,
but at least we know where we stand and
so since then I would say particularly
with in many ways,
particularly with the work of yoga and
and everything that's come out of that
which is the deeper study of mythology
and its meanings and we'd been trying to
address that.
The issue that you brought up and trying
to solve the problem and the problem is
something like the reunification of the
spirit of mankind.
It's something like that.
Well,
we're slogging through it,
man.
That's it.
That's why you're all here,
at least in part.
So we'll see how far we can get by at
this rate.
We'll get to like the twelfth verse in
the first,
but that's the aim,
you know.
Okay.
So first we have access to the slides.
Yes.
You'll be in the,
there'll be in the video.
I could also make them available as
slides.
Slides.
Yeah.
Well that's okay.
I'll return to this when we,
when we get going again.
So.
Awesome.
You mentioned the significant.
Oh yeah.
Different colors represent the distance
between the,
um,
the cross references.
Yeah.
Is the Holy Spirit as the logos?
Well,
I'll talk about that more next time.
I mean,
I think that the best answer to that is
I'll talk more about that next time.
I mean,
I think of them as overlapping
metaphorical domains.
You know,
when the descriptions I put up the
fatherly aspect,
the second aspect and the spirit aspect.
You could swap a lot of those,
you know,
it's kind of arbitrary,
but I think they're,
I think the trinitarian idea is trying
to get forward.
The notion that the locus of the divine
is,
is it's the same thing in its essence,
but it exists in a multiplicity.
It exists as the spirit of tradition,
it exists as the living individual in
the in time and space and that it exists
as the spirit that,
that,
that and is consciousness,
something like that that we all share,
which,
which you know,
young would have thought about that as
something like the capacity for the
individual to realize that tragedy and
redemption of Christ in their individual
life and that's something like your
capacity to voluntarily accept the
tragic conditions of your exist in San
to move forward to something resembling
paradise.
Regardless of that,
you know as something that's intrinsic
to you and I think that's associated
with the idea of the pentecost and,
and,
and the Holy Spirit,
all of that.
It's so that that's as good as I can do
in a short period of time.
So
Yup.
Contract or a legal system.
Religion.
I think it's because it's because of
the,
the gap between what we articulated,
what we don't know.
Something has to fill that gap.
Like I think the law could be,
could,
could replace it if the law was total,
but it isn't it,
it's,
it's bounded and the incorrect and
there's something in wrists.
It has to rest on something inside
that's like this mediator between what
we articulate and what we don't
understand.
It's something like custom.
It's something like expectation.
It's something like the intrinsic sense
of justice,
you know that the law itself is aiming
at and those aren't fully articulated,
but without them there'd be no
grounding.
Like without the body,
the law would be a dictionary,
you know,
and if you don't know what a word means,
using the dictionary is helpful,
but not that because like unless you've
had the experience of anger,
the dictionary can't tell you what anger
means.
It's just refers to other words,
but the words themselves refer to
something else and the law refers to
something else and without that it has
to be in tune with that.
Something else has to be in accordance
with it.
And so I don't think we can ever
delineate the proper body of laws and
that's also why you like ideological
utopias.
See,
the ideological utopia is dispensed with
the transcendent.
They say,
this is what we need to do.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
No,
that's not good.
You have to leave space for what you
kind of known for what you don't know
and I mean,
you know in the story of the Tower of
Babel,
human beings make this massive building.
It's supposed to reach up to the heavens
so that it'll take the place of God.
Well,
that's.
That's the earliest warning we have of
the danger of making things so big that
you confuse them with God and God gets
irritated and comes down and makes
everybody speak different languages and
scatters them.
It's like,
well,
that's what happens when you try to make
something a totality is that it starts
to fragment inside and disintegrates
into catastrophe and so it's,
it's almost as if we have to maintain
this articulated space inside the dream,
inside the customer,
something like that because otherwise it
doesn't work.
And I think that's the same as having
respect for the fact that we have
bodies.
You know,
we're not just abstract creatures that
follow rules.
We're not that at all,
we only follow certain rules,
we won't follow the other ones and our
societies will crumble.
And so,
and we just don't know enough to
articulate the entire landscape of
behavior with articulated rules.
Not at all.
We can't do it.
It's beyond us.
Yep.
Thanks for the talk.
My question is also about dreams.
Uh,
you spoke about dreams as a,
like a representation of truth and
universal truths that,
uh,
can be interpreted into like myths and,
and religion and uh,
as,
as you say,
it's very beneficial for the individual
and it sounds like also for,
for the society as well because not
everyone can as easily.
I'm a rep,
remember their dreams are or interpreted
their creams like that.
And also it's,
it's,
um,
like broadcast at to,
to all of society for their benefits.
So I guess I'm wondering what the
evolutionary advantage of dreams are.
And my question would be,
do you think that dreams,
I'm a suggests some sort of a
evolutionary group selection such that
like groups that don't have these dreams
that are represented into myths and
religion to be think they,
they didn't as well.
Okay,
so I'm not gonna answer the second part
of that question because I'd have to go
far too far off at a tangent for me to
manage right now,
but I can answer the first part being
what happens when you're dreaming.
There's a little switch so to speak,
in your brain that shuts off when you're
dreaming and it stops you from moving,
right?
It shuts everything off except your eyes
because you know you're moving your eyes
back and forth.
You're not going to get run around and
get eaten by a lion.
It's okay to move your eyes,
but the rescue was standing exactly
where it is.
Then you can run these simulations and
so what's happening at night,
and this is a fairly well accepted
theory of dreaming.
We know that dreams update memories and
help consolidate memories.
They also help you forget,
but what seems to be happening at night
is that you're.
You're running the underlying
architecture of your cognitive ability
in different simulations,
but we're,
and it's cost free because you're
paralyzed,
you're not running around.
They're owed in the world investigating,
so it's part of the manner in which your
brain experiments with the way the world
can be represented and so and it seems
absolutely necessary and I mean if you
deprive people of rem sleep,
they don't stay sane very long.
There's something necessary about the
dreaming process to maintenance of the,
of,
of articulated sanity.
So you're doing some kind of
organization at night when you descend
into that chaos.
And partly what seems to happen is that
your categorical no,
your categories have boundaries,
right?
Sometimes you don't have the categories
correct and so the boundaries have to
loosen and other things need to be put
into categories where some things
shunted away and in the dream the
category structure loosens,
which is why dreams are so cute,
but they're experimenting.
It's your mind is experimenting with the
underlying categorical structure of
imagination and trying to update your,
your mode of being in the world.
Dreams often concentrate on things that
provoke anxiety.
So if you wake people up when they're
dreaming,
the most commonly reported emotion is
anxiety.
And so the dream is like the first
stages of the attempt to contend with
the unknown.
And so the dream is half unknown and
half known,
which is also why it's so peculiar,
you know,
because you kind of understand it,
but you don't really.
And it,
it,
it partakes of the unknown and of the
note and it's the bridge between the
two,
something like that.
So,
um,
okay.
So my question is kind of two parts.
The first one is just like a general
question and then just the application
of the question.
So my first question is,
do you think that consciousness and
being hood are inextricably,
inextricably linked?
And then secondly,
so if there was something like a
supercomputer that one could have
theoretically a perfect brain of a
person in it,
does that thing then become the same
person as the person who was before?
So is
there a transcendence he to be in hood
but not too conscious.
Okay.
So the first question is,
well,
I would say that the kind of being that
these stories are concerned with is
absolutely dependent on consciousness.
Now whether or not that means that being
as such as dependent on consciousness
actually depends on how you define Ba.
Right?
So it's always tricky when you ask an a
if is a,
an instant,
an example of b.
There was a tricky question because it
depends on how you define the two,
but for our purposes,
the being that we're discussing that's
represented in these stories is
intrinsically associated with conscious
experience.
And consciousness is given this
constitutive role.
It says that the experience that we're
talking about would not exist if
consciousness did not exist.
So you can think about it as a kind of
game in a way and then you have to
decide for yourself whether that's a
game that can be generalized.
And I won't answer the second part.
Okay.
If you don't mind.
Alright.
So two part question.
First one
very quick,
almost admin.
If we want to read the biblical stories
that you're referring to is a particular
version,
edition,
source publisher.
Oh,
I'll bring the thing I like next week,
which is a,
I think the reader's digest published it
of all things,
but it's,
uh,
it,
it lays out the narratives in a
different format.
It's easy.
I find it much easier to read.
So I'll show it to you and I'll bring it
next time and show it to you.
The main question is one of the main
reasons why I'm interested in so much of
your work and I think as well as you
kind of liberalism at the door and you
open up another door to have a much more
deeper meaning in your interview with
Trans Liminal media.
You mentioned his eyeballs,
book of the serpent,
the tree and vision,
and you note that we as a species are
very good at recognizing camouflage
patterns of snakes,
particularly in the law field of vision.
And you further note that visual
acuities is correlated with that and
that it could bold.
And you summarize that by saying the
following.
I'm paraphrasing you.
You say what gives you vision?
Snakes do.
That's what it says in Genesis.
What else gives you vision?
Fruit.
That's also right.
That's why we have color vision.
What makes you self conscious?
Fear Man,
woman.
That's eve.
And so I understand that the elementary
level,
some of the concepts that you have about
representations,
dreams,
abstractions,
et Cetera,
but kind of raises the question for me.
You know,
I'm not accusing you of any creationism
or literalism.
What's your point?
Why did you make that connection?
What's the meaning of the story of
Genesis Visa VI Liberals Book?
No problem.
We're gonna as soon as I get past this
first,
genesis one,
we're gonna.
We're gonna hit that hard partly.
Are you at all suggesting that one?
Yes,
I'm suggesting that it foreshadowed it
and and I think they're the same thing.
I mean his belt and her books plays with
that idea metaphorically,
but she never really takes it seriously,
which is no problem.
I mean,
there's only so much you can take
seriously and she did a fine job of what
you did,
but I'll talk about that a lot because
it's a very complicated issue.
I mean,
I would say to begin with that,
the,
that,
the systems that you use to deal with
radical uncertainty or the same systems
that you're primate ancestors evolved to
deal with snakes.
That's a good start.
So.
Okay.
One more and then we're done.
I'm an aerospace science engineer and an
expert computer programmer and I have
three rapid fire questions,
so I'm going to get through quick.
Based on your opinion of where the
university is now standing in terms of
humanities and social sciences,
is mathematics more powerful than
articulated speech?
I'm not sure.
I'm not exactly sure how the more
powerful to study mathematics and
science in university.
Well,
it depends on what you mean by power,
I guess.
I mean obviously studying mathematics
and computer science makes you insanely
powerful.
The question is to what end,
and I don't think that you can extract
an answer to that from the study of
mathematics.
The humanities are there to ground
people in proper citizen hood.
That's,
that's a way of thinking about it and so
yes,
it makes you powerful,
but then the question is who has the
power?
Because it might not be you,
it might be the mathematics,
so to speak,
you know,
because you never know what you're an
agent of precisely and so harvest.
Yeah.
Well look,
I've got nothing against computer
programmers.
I mean more power to you guys and
mathematicians as well,
but the tool,
so it has to be a two,
right?
It has to be a tool.
I'll have something and what the
humanities were forward to take was to
tell people what the tools shouldn't be
used for and so the tools themselves are
crazily powerful,
but that's,
that's not necessarily,
you know,
an,
an untrammeled good.
So I have to stop because.
Okay.
Quick.
You want to answer this question?
Okay.
You were in this I guess one room in a
museum in New York seeing some original
renaissance art work masterpiece.
These are generally accepted as amazing
artifacts.
Okay.
Does a,
an original work of art as opposed to a
high fidelity reproduction contained the
spirit of the artist who created it and
does this account for the disparity and
how much you'd have to pay for it.
It does impart a good portrait artist.
And uh,
one of the things he pointed out about a
great portrait is that it actually
contains time.
So you know,
because a photograph is one instant,
but a portrait is you layered on,
you layered on you late.
So it's gonna thickness,
you know,
when there,
I think you can see that thickness in
the original,
but it's also a direct manifestation of
that creative act of perception.
And I don't think you get that.
You just can't get the fidelity of the
original with the reproduction.
But there's more to it than that too
because the painting doesn't end with
the frame.
You know,
like we tend to think of the painting
itself as the object,
but,
but most objects are,
are densely innervated with hisd with
historical context.
And you can say,
well the historical context isn't the
object,
but it depends on what you mean by the
object.
And often people when they buy a piece
of a painting are buying the historical
context and you just don't get that with
the reproduction.
It's a kind of magic.
It's like,
do you want to have Elvis Presley's
guitar or another guitar just like it
while you want to have Elvis's guitar.
It's why you can't tell it's Elvis's
guitar by looking at it.
Perfect reproduction.
Well,
it is at the level of detail,
but not at the level of context.
That's how it looks to me.
Okay.
We gotta go.
Thank you.